foreign
open the hearing on sb12
and I recognize
the prime sponsor
Senator Waters
well good morning Mr chairman members of
the committee Senator David Senator
David Waters District 4 and I'm always
glad to be back in my home committee
room I was here my terms in the house
2008 to 12 and I'd say you know not much
has changed but it's good to be here and
I'm introducing uh Senate Bill 12
relative to the leasing of seasonal
camps
a lots by the fishing game uh Department
this is a bill on behalf of the
department
um and it uh maintains the fish and game
Department's handling of State leases
and and it makes them consistent now
with other state agencies in terms of
the length of a lease that can be put
forward by by making that consistent at
the five five not more than five uh
years
um right now under RSA 12 212 10B says
any at least for buildings or lands is
longer than cumulative period of 30 days
must be administered in accordance with
RSA 440
and take a look at that and you can see
the paperwork involved multi-layered
lengthy process of approval Eleven
Hundred Dollar administrative charge to
the lessee
for each renewable release give me a
break sorry that's an aside the proposed
change will have the language mirror
what exists in RSA 439 Ford colon 39.
and that's State leases are up to five
years before needing approval of the
governor and Council and the long-range
Capital planning committee but let me
know that if the lease you know is uh
going to be over five years in the 7 500
then it goes to Governor Council like
every other lease which it what it
should do now um let's get to why this
is really important for the Department
to have this um they currently manage
the seasonal Camp lease program for the
Connecticut Lakes Natural Area up in the
north country
um those leases are allowed for up to
five years
um don't require that process
um but we have also the department of
seasonal Camp wants
um they own some and they you know might
be acquiring another one and uh for
those as they come in ought to be under
this five-year system and I think that
if you're visiting the fish and game Run
operations
um these are great they're opportunity
for families they mean that these these
Camp Watts instead of being sold for
development or some other thing that
they they their uses get maintained
people can can use them and that's why
they like to go up to the up to the
north uh North Country
um and what it does it means it'll allow
the department if it requires property
that have existing camps
um that'll streamline the Department's
efforts regulate them and provide a more
efficient approach for managing uh
renewals so this bill was uh worked up
by Dan Bergeron who's here chief of
wildlife fish and game and uh Betsy
McNaughton land agent for the department
they can ask her ask you know answer any
more questions that you might have about
the details of it but um this makes a
lot of sense to me thank you Mr chairman
thank you are there any questions
you're recognized
hi representative Morton from Amherst
um I'm wondering you mentioned the
Connecticut Lakes region is already
Under The Five-Year and about how many
Lots or or sites is that and then
changing this to everyone going to five
year how many more does that add to the
process
yeah I think I'm gonna let um the
department talk to that but I'll just
say that I mentioned that because that's
an example of what is successful and as
consistent with the other the other way
the way other state agencies do things
and so it's it's saying that works let's
let it work for the other ones and they
can tell you about the actual number of
lots that we're talking about
great thank you thank you thank you and
uh representative Khan
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
senator for taking my question Senator
can you tell us that how this uh uh bill
was
taken by the Senate you know when you
had your hearing
uh unanimous in committee and consent on
the floor thank you yeah
thank you uh any other questions
representative Ming
thank you Mr chair
um
Senator the uh in the in the first
paragraph it says short-term short-term
use of buildings or lands
um
that existed when the period was 30 days
by not CH by not taking that out is
there any implication
um
by increasing the five-year limit to
I guess the
I guess what I'm asking it does the does
the definition of short-term change by
increasing
the upper limit on on the term
um thanks for your question
representative I I I don't I don't think
so I mean people can at least for as
long as they want to lose but it's just
saying that you know the pre the statute
now says that if it's more than 30 days
you've got to go through that whole
process and do it again where if you
want to go up to five years hey this is
that's what we do with other state
agencies and you'd be able to do it here
too okay but I think there may be some
more details there and
okay thank you
thank you uh do you have a follow-up uh
not a follow-up but a different question
go ahead thank you Mr chair
um so this has to do with um the fact
that it references a contract and a
lease is there any intent to contract
out of
um any issue that doesn't have to do
with leasing the land
but that's the question I'm going to let
the depart okay all right sure thank you
okay any further questions
seeing none thank you Senator thank you
I'll see you in a little while
thank you
chair now recognizes Dan Bergeron from
uh fish and game
good morning chairman Spillane members
of the committee um thank you for having
me testify here before you today I'm the
chief of the wildlife division at New
Hampshire Fish and Game department
Senator Waters did a great job
summarizing why we we brought this bill
forward so I'll try and make mine a
little bit more brief I can speak to
your question in terms of how many so
the department doesn't really look for
properties that have camps or any other
buildings on them that said we also
don't want to be prevented from
obtaining good conservation land or
wildlife habitat just because a seasonal
Camp is there so we have there's a three
camps on the Connecticut Lakes Natural
Area we have two other camps on
different properties we're in the
process of obtaining another property
that would have a sixth Camp
these camps typically in the northern
part of the state they're part of the
culture and the Heritage up there so we
would like to be able to maintain that
those when possible and again this this
bill would streamline our process
because now we're working under two
different sets of rsas one for our
Connecticut lakes and then one for
everything else this would make
everything language on all these
consistent the process consistent it
would make it consistent with other
agencies dncr D.O.T all have similar
language in there in their rsas in terms
of how they deal with properties like
this
and I believe you had some handout for
everybody yes I have tested my written
testimony here if you could hand that to
representative Ming he'll take one and
hand it down thank you
are there any questions for uh Mr
Bergeron yes uh
you can go Carol
uh thank you Mr chair uh good morning
thanks for taking my question I'm
following up on what rep representative
Ming asked is there
is there and is there a definition of
short-term use of buildings and does
this allow someone to rent one of these
camps for five years
I'm not aware of a definition of
short-term use
um
similar to what Senator Waters had
pointed out this would make language
consistent you could go up to five years
but it certainly could be shorter than
that so with the max being five years
follow up thank you so so a a a single
entity can lease for five years yes one
of these okay thank you
and go ahead representative Smith thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question how many properties now
be the leased or contracted are for
periods more than 30 days is it all of
them
I'll look to Betsy McNaughton who's our
land agent she would be more familiar
with that
if she'd like to join you at the table
she can do so thank you
good morning chairman I'm Betsy
McNaughton I'm the land agent I'm the
one who administers these at uh fish and
game
um and I'm sorry repeat your question
again
how many of how many Parcels or
properties that at least are contracted
for are for periods of longer than 30
days
all of the camp leases seasonal Camp
leases are um there they are longer than
30 days
um I usually do a lease document for
four years and talking about the
Connecticut Lakes that's the one that's
been in place for
I want to say 20 years
um so I do the lease document for four
years and within that lease document
there's a payment schedule for those
four years
and then the other three two
Camp lots that we own as well and plus
this one coming on soon will be the next
three
um
we haven't had them long enough to I
mean they've they've gone through the
what I've called the chord process which
is the 440 the RSA 440 process with long
range and cord
um they've gone through it I think twice
so
it's very time consuming process
can I also make one clarification
certainly you're up there to testify
camps they own the building we own the
land underneath
um so they're leasing the space where
the building is and this has been
um
they've been in the families for
generations and so it's not that we're
changing uh leases every five years
we're these these leases have been
consistent with the family members that
have been there for Generations
so I'll take an opportunity to ask a
question myself because that was very
clarifying and it's something I didn't
get from the previous discussion so this
is more like um a mobile home park where
they own the state is owning the land
underneath but the people own the
building on top of it yeah except for
they're not mobile homes well I
understand but it's the same methodology
where the the lease is required because
they're on the property that they don't
own but the building is theirs yes so
they're required to do all the
maintenance of the building
but they have to have the the leasing
through the state because of the land
use correct correct
thank you
representative Ming you're recognized
thank you Mr chair I guess I'll just
ask my question again about contract
versus lease is there anything that's
going to be contracted that doesn't have
to do with
um the land or the buildings
not that I'm aware of okay so uh
follow-up
follow-up thank you
um
so I I would just anticipate that it's
for flexibilities sake
um to specify contract because contract
is kind of a bigger term right right
um Elise is a type of contract
but a contract is not a type of lease
that
that's just my question that it only has
to do with the buildings in the land
right correct yes okay thank you
okay uh representative Ouellette
followed by representative Khan
just to make a statement and clarify a
little bit what they said the lease of
camps has gone on for Generations up in
the North Country much of it was done
through
Paper Company lands where you actually
built your Camp rented a piece of
property and and it's been like that for
a hundred years so this isn't something
new or something they've done it's a
tradition in North Country it's been
going on for Generations
thank you all right representative Khan
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question uh my question is if
this uh Senate Bill 12 passes is there
any extra cost to the department or the
New Hampshire taxpayers
no there would be no additional cost
this would actually streamline the
process and likely save money thank you
any further questions
seeing none uh thank you very much for
your testimony today thank you is there
anybody in here who has not had a chance
to speak who wishes to do so
not seeing anyone I'm going to close the
hearing a public hearing on sb12
and it is
time to open up the hearing on sb18
I'll recognize the prime sponsor rep
Senator Lang
thank you Mr chairman I'm trying to get
used to that myself
so Mr chairman um and committee members
thank you it's great to be back in this
room uh it's been uh I did want to walk
up to my chair Mr chairman and take my
seat again but I guess I realize I'm on
this side of the microphone over here
um so I'm introducing Senate bill 18.
this is essentially a housekeeping
measure that does two things first it
allows for electronic or email
confirmation of a duck stamp purchased
in lieu of an actual physical stamp the
intent is to be consistent with Federal
practice that allows for an electronic
stamp as well as take into consideration
off the lengthy time that it takes
between the purchase of a duck stamp and
the actual physical receipt getting it
for the hunter the second thing this
does is clean up some statute it
includes a in a conviction of an
unlawful discharge with firearm within
an urban area a compact urban area which
is governed by RSA 64413 as the grounds
for suspension of a revocation of a
license issued by Fish and Game
the intent is to create consistency
between the violation of RSA 207 colon
3-a which prohibits the discharge of
firearm within 300 feet of a dwelling in
a violation results in the suspension
revocation and the same violation as the
same violation in RSA
64413 that does not result in suspension
we need to First make uh make this
change in law so that we can clean up
the rules to be consistent on the
application of the penalty there is
somebody here from fish and game but
again the biggest part of this is again
it simplifies the licensing process for
our hunters and fishermen in our state
and the second thing it does it puts the
discharge of a weapon in a cartilage and
a dischargeable weapon in a compact or
Urban compact area on on par with each
other that will result in the suspension
of a license
happy to take any questions but this is
also the major over here we'll probably
answer the questions way better than me
thank you for your testimony Senator are
there any questions for Senator Lang
seeing none thank you so much damn I'm
good
and do I have a card for you sir
foreign
the chair calls major Dave Walsh from
Fish and Game
good morning Mr chairman Mr committee my
name is Dave Walsh I am the assistant
chief of law enforcement for fish and
game as Senator Lang said this is a
housekeeping measure the first part uh
just to give you a brief introduction
anybody who waterfowl hunts in New
Hampshire has to buy a federal stamp
currently the law in New Hampshire is
you must have that on your person before
you hunt now the federal government
sells these stamps online and they give
you an electronic confirmation that you
bought it but we the way Allah is
written prohibits people from using that
electronic confirmation so this cleans
it up so if you go out and buy a stamp
online you could hunt that day because
you get that electronic confirmation and
you have 45 days until the stamp comes
in the mail so it makes it easier for
hunters and then the second part is the
discharge of a firearm in a compact Zone
currently we don't have the ability to
suspend a license so if somebody shoots
a firearm while hunting in a playground
for example in an urban area if they're
not technically within 300 feet of a
building would have to charge them with
another stat with the statute and we
wouldn't be able to suspend for them so
it cleans up the the suspension um for
discharging while hunting in a compact
Zone
thank you any questions for the major
all right did you have one
go ahead representative thank you Mr
chair
um I read this last night over again so
maybe it was late and maybe I'm asking a
question that's not relevant
should 207 colon 3A that's firearm
discharge while hunting for 300 feet is
there a reason that isn't in here or
should it be in here so we have the
ability to spend for that violation but
there are instances where somebody could
not violate that but still be within a
compact Zone okay so it doesn't need to
be referenced in the in this bill it
does not okay thank you very much thank
you
thank you any other questions okay then
I have one
major
um it's my understanding from uh
experience hunting waterfowl myself that
you need to print your signature across
that duck stamp to make it valid and to
also basically it's the same as a
cancellation Mark in the post office
uh it's yours now and I know that in
stamp collecting the ones without a
signature are worth a lot more than the
ones that have been signed and so I'm
just wondering if this allowing you to
use an electronic copy that has no
signature would allow them to then take
the duck stamp without a signature and
put it away somewhere and save it as a
more valuable thing and not have their
signature attached has the federal
government changed the regulations
regarding signing the stamps and is
there a way that
um we're handling that excellent
question so no the way the the federal
government and the way this law is
written is that electronic confirmation
is good for 45 days when you get your
license or stamp in the mail then you
have to put it on your license and sign
it
thank you for clarifying that yep
it's really for the last minute people
that gotcha any further questions
go ahead representative Smith thank you
Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question I think I know the answer to
this but I'm going to ask it anyway if
you're in a compact Zone and you are
hunting but you're hunting and you have
permission obviously it is then deemed
legal correct correct and the only folks
that can give permission in a compact
zone is actually the chief of police of
that city of town by Statute so follow
up
follow-up oh okay for clarity a
landowner cannot give permission just
the chief of police in a compact Zone in
a compact Zone thank you
okay thank you any further questions
seeing none thank you thank you sir
is there anyone here who wishes to speak
who has not had a chance to speak
okay
seeing none I'm going to close the
public hearing on sb18
and we have uh about 20 minutes before
we can start the next hearing on SB 14
so we will be taking a short break
uh yeah we can
does anybody have any objections to
executing these two bills
all right let's go ahead and do that
we we have we have a uh yeah the 11th
came in right we have 11 and and I have
agreement of the the ranking member from
the other side so we can exec
um are you prepared we'll wait until the
clerk is prepared
if anybody needs to take a five minute
break let's do that and we'll come back
in exactly
okay
whoops
the
uh
yeah
thank you
I'm going to now open the exact session
on sb12
and I'm going to look to uh
representative goalie for a motion
thank you Mr chair I move uh to pass on
Senate bill 12.
it's been moved uh to pass do we have a
second
by rep pair
any discussion on this before we get
into it
okay we'll move straight to the voting
then the clerk may call the roll
representative goalie
yes
representative Khan
representative Smith
yes
representative kofalt and Tudor and
Bartlett are absent representative Brown
yes representative nutting are absent
representative Willett yes
representative Harvey
yes sorry
thank you
representative Fox yes representative
Ming
yes representative Morton yes
representative page yes
representative pair yes
and representative Roser is absent and
Chairman's Blaine that's a yes
so we have 11 years 0
Nays and everyone's fine with consent
for that it will go on consent do we
need to have a uh majority opinion
written for that we probably should in
case somebody pulls it
would you be willing to do that all
right representative goalie will write
our uh opinion got it
that closes the exact session on sb12 I
will open the exact session on sb18
and I will look to uh you want someone
else to do this one
all right representative goalie for a
motion
thank you Mr chair I move
ought to pass on Senate bill 18.
we have a motion of ought to pass do we
have a second
okay representative page opened his
mouth first so we've got a second from
representative page all the hands went
up at once
um okay it's been uh moved and seconded
we can now open discussion on that is
there any discussion on this before we
go into the voting mode
you're recognized thank you Mr chair
just briefly that uh this puts uh the
purchase of duck stamps
they're on par with the federal language
allowing a person to buy the stamp and
have it electronically for 45 days as
well as
allowing for where are they discharged
and then
Urban compact uh clarifying that statute
any body else
seeing nothing I will go ahead and ask
the clerk to call the roll
thank you
representative goalie yes
representative Khan yeah representative
Smith
yes representative kofo Tudor and
Bartlett are absent representative Brown
that's me yes representative Corcoran
and nutting are absent representative
Willett yes
representative Harvey Reed and Ford are
absent representative Fox
representative Ming
yes representative Morton yes
representative page yes
representative pair yet Excuse me yes
thank you representative Rosner is
absent and Chairman's Blaine that's a
yes uh that would be 11 years zero Nays
again everyone else fine with consent
again yes and do you want to write the
opinion on that one as well okay uh
representative goalie will write the
opinion yep
and I will close the exact session on
sb18
we still have 15 minutes before we can
start uh the next bill so you all can
have a break if you want
that'll work
I'll take the opportunity while
everyone's here to and we're on a break
here to mention to everybody that uh did
some research that the committee
researcher has dropped off uh there's a
third item that he's working on before
we exec uh other bills
um that will show a comparison and
contrast between the Midwest hunting
style and the Northeast hunting style uh
and the benefits and drawbacks to each
of those Styles
um what we've got here is uh what I
requested as far as uh providing for
your information what's currently
prohibited within 300 feet of an
occupied dwelling what the current
season is for night hunting coyote and
um what current things are required to
have your name or identification
attached as far as hunting gear and then
um all of the information about current
use and the important part that you'll
want to pay attention to is the last
page where it talks about the 20 extra
discount
those are the areas that may come into
play in your mind and so there's some
additional information for you
oh no
we
didn't
okay
uh
absolutely
one of the things I passed
my researcher could do is to dig up a
comparison with it because a lot of
people
don't know about hunting in the midwest
it's a totally different methodology and
we like our open land right
out there everything is quite proficient
only unless it's public land and it's
out in the midwest what you find is uh
welcome people put the different private
plans right and everyone else's praying
about our public work
um
do you know which beginning that kind of
information so he can provide
okay
I don't know where I don't know if the
fish and wildlife
I know there are
unique states
foreign
questions
basically
everyone
about it Exchange
take it down
thank you
foreign
is
ability information
I don't
know again
oh no yeah
[Music]
maybe next year
the peaches
[Music]
thank you
bro
Oke
rejoice
yes
how are you senator
thank you very much
thank you
[Music]
um
what's up
how are you guys doing pretty good
that was awesome
thank you
water
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee Senator David Waters District
4 introducing Senate bill 14
at the request to The Fish and Game
Commission uh provides guidance and
clarification on the use of game cameras
for hunting
um I say it's at the requested apartment
but really this is an issue that we all
have been working on for several years
um I hope that a lot of this looks
familiar to you from House Bill 490
which I I think got us a long way
towards where we needed to be on this
but we just couldn't get there in a
committee conference
last year
so um let me just step back for a moment
I feel like I'm on the game camera right
now but you can't come get me for 24
hours all right
um anyways uh let me just talk a little
bit about the background here what the
what the larger issues are and why I
think you know Senator Pearl and the and
the department and everybody else who
worked on the Senate we came up with
something for you to I think you can
work with too
um
you know as I said I've been a member I
was members of the committee I'm a
strong supporter of hunting
and hunting rights in the state and this
new technology has come in and it is it
is useful for hunting and I think that
there needs that needs to be recognized
as something useful for hunters
we also know you know New Hampshire
folks are pretty pretty uh set on their
privacy aren't they especially on their
property and so you know they are upset
a lot we heard a lot because people are
finding game cameras and wondering well
what can they record uh on on the
property and who's who's doing this to
know what happens with those images
so you know this is one of those ones
where you have to do really two
conflicting um things here and and what
do we do about it so what we did in the
bill
was we you know did some definitional
work on a game camera
um then importantly a 24-hour time frame
between viewing wildlife and then taking
that animal which I think kind of makes
sense for you know Fair hunt Fair Chase
principles
um then as uh we move on to the kind of
management of this
that annual written or posted permission
so if you you know it's always good if
you're going to hunt somebody's land
have a relationship with that landowner
right
um so this would be that you would go
and you know do I have permission
and you have a relationship with that
person you'd probably tell them where
you're going to put your camera and so
on and so forth and explain it to them
and then you can get the written
permission
a landowner may just decide to post
that it's okay
you know the game cameras are all right
here
um
then
require the cameras to be labeled with a
name and contact information of the
owner and that really addresses the fact
that we need information because then it
should only be a law or conservation
officer that seizes unauthorized cameras
and I think that's often important
because of the property rights issues
that we can get in if somebody goes out
a property owner goes out there or
somebody else and takes down a camera
you know it is somebody's property and
that can that can create some problems
so if you find a camera you can report
it all our conservation officer can come
out
uh remove it and uh they would have the
contact information
there to do that
um then there are some exceptions here
that you'll see in the bill scientific
permits warrants Fish and Game staff and
so on which is you know what you would
expect and then there's a penalty
established for violations here
um as we heard in the Senate and I'm
sure you heard on 490 last year
um this this use of game cameras has
become a really major concern for land
owners
fish and game was receiving lots of
complaints we didn't really have a ways
to manage this problem
um and so we thought it was we put the
bill together we might have a way to
satisfy those competing needs and
provide some it's enforceable and
reasonable for fish and game
landowners and Hunters I do want to note
in the Senate the New Hampshire Farm
Bureau
supports it Timberland Association
supports it
and New Hampshire Wildlife Federation
along with fish and games so I think
would you know you get those folks to
say
that this really protects um landowners
rights and uh and and and funding
hunting as well I think we we've got a
pretty good place Colonel Jordan is here
who can talk a lot about their
experience with game cameras the kind of
complaints they're getting the issues
they're running into and why the way we
put together
the details of this I think will work so
glad to take any questions uh on it and
um
thank you Mr chairman are there any
questions for Senator Waters
okay I have one myself yes
um Senator Waters we've heard uh some
people via email and such that are
hesitant with putting their name on the
camera they don't have a problem with a
phone number
um but we also heard from fish and game
that they would be happy to entertain
the fact that somebody could write their
license number their hunting license
number on there which makes it
identifiable if somebody calls fish and
game and says it's this license number
they can figure out who it is but it
prevents somebody from being doxxed by
an anti-hunter if they don't have their
name on there where it says name and
contact information in the bill would
you be open to that being modified to
just say uh somehow they're identifying
information and phone number thanks
sounds like a good idea to me thank you
uh I do have a follow-up question uh the
section that does not prohibit and has
all the exceptions in it I heard from
some landowners that would still like to
know that fish and games putting a
camera on their property or that uh
you know any of these other reasons is
there a reason why the landowner is not
being notified if it's a fish and game
looking for a an animal and wanted to do
some research on their property or if
it's a scientist putting a camera out or
any of these other situations because I
heard from some landowners that said
yeah this is well and good but I want to
know efficient games doing it too
yeah thanks for that on it's an
interesting point
um and I think Colonel Jordan and others
will address it I I do think that
you know when you get into that let's
consider carefully if it's a warrant
you know maybe you don't want to do that
um if there are some other purposes
but I I think that that probably could
be wiggled to to deal with the concern
that you're mentioning while also
protecting the kind of needs of the
department in law enforcement
thank you and anybody else have a
question now yes uh representative Smith
thank you Mr chairman thank you senator
for taking my question I I have a two or
three questions which I just go with
them
one at a time I'll give you follow-ups
as needed
just to follow up on uh the Chairman's
comments
um
regarding actually let me just go back
a lot of landowners are absentee
landowners large tracts of land they're
not present don't you think this will be
logistical headache for them to try to
accommodate say 100 200 requests for
game cam replacements
that's your question
um
you know if they're absentee I mean it's
an interesting thought I mean I I'm kind
of pausing because I it's hard for me to
imagine 100 200 requests I mean you know
how Hunters are when they stake out
there where they're going to hunt and
they're very they're very careful about
what we're looking and where they hunt
maybe have for several years and where
they're gonna Place their cameras so
um
and I would say if you're an absentee
landlord
maybe you just put out that's one reason
of the permission thing you just posted
you want to put your camera out go ahead
if you don't like that idea then people
can contact you and you know you're if
you're the owner of record and
I mean I I
I
I'm really afraid that we're going to
get to a situation where more and more
land is unavailable for hunting
you know and and keeping keeping Land
open for hunting is really important and
I was concerned that
you know the game camera issue if we
didn't do something about it might
um end up just more and more owners
might just post their land and that that
to me would be a terrible outcome
um so I understand the problem you're
identifying I'm not you know I don't
think it's unmanageable frankly under
the bill
follow up
thank you um what are the posting
requirements for example no trespassing
signs have to be I think one every 300
feet
is this going to have a minimum number
of signs or some property boundaries
could be three four five six eight miles
long how do you go about ensuring
posting requirements are met
if you don't mind I'll let Colonel
Jordan talk talk through that okay
perhaps it
anything else one more follow-up
follow-up again
um on a different topic regarding
labeling of the camera what is to
prevent someone from putting Humphrey
Bogart on the camera with the fictitious
phone number because anyone could put
anything they want to satisfy the
requirements
uh thank you um if people choose to
break the law they can find all kinds of
creative ways to do it but I kind of
know the Humphrey Bogart isn't doing
much hunting anymore but I mean I don't
mean to be facetious I think that
there's a if there's a if somebody has
falsified a record on that they are
potentially subject for a violation and
I suspect Fish and Game officers might
find a good way to catch that person
further questions
representative Ming
thank you Mr chair
um thank you Senator waters for taking
my question uh the 24-hour waiting
period it says remote viewing does that
mean only game cameras that transmit
photos and videos or is that is it
supposed to include a game camera that
you have to actually go
pick up view the pictures
um thanks for your question my
understanding of the technology is that
uh you're downloading it the images
so it is remote
you're receiving a remote I don't know
I'm not sure I could understood the
question but uh nope follow it follow up
thank you Mr chair
um so I have a game camera that doesn't
transmit pictures I can pick it up and
view the pictures on the camera itself
um
so
it's I I wouldn't necessarily classify
that as
remote is is the intent that it should
just be
all cameras all game cam all game
cameras or is it
are they the game cameras if you don't
mind if I step in uh Senator uh the the
key word here is uh remotely viewing
okay here
um and we went through this with the
bill last year uh it's it does not
mean that the ones you have to go out
and take the camera card out or to view
it out on the camera itself has to have
that 24 hour period it's only when
you've when you've viewed the image of
the animal remotely and that's why it
says remotely viewing in there thank you
Mr chairman and I think you know that
that's the way I I think that's what it
does say so I just checked to make sure
it had the word remotely viewing still
in it I was like well did that fall out
somehow yeah and I think that if
somebody comes out and you know they're
not getting them remotely they come out
and they look at them I don't think the
24 I don't think the 24 hours
the deer comes to see you yep undown on
the camera they're gonna be pretty
scarce anyways okay is that it uh yeah
that's it thank you representative Ming
are there any other questions I will ask
you one more on as I as I let you go
have you thought about putting a
companion bill in through criminal
justice because as I pointed out to uh
the Timberland Owners Association the
Farm Bureau and the Wildlife Federation
uh a lot of these cameras because
they've come down in price and they're
so available are being used uh by people
who are not hunters and putting these
regulations in the hunting codes does
not provide for penalties for their
misuse on the criminal side
for somebody who say
is using it as a private detective to
see if somebody is uh saying that
they're disabled and taking work
workman's comp when they're not does not
prohibit the use by stalkers to stalk
somebody does not prohibit the use by
wild wildlife viewers who aren't Hunters
so if I'm a bird watcher and I want to
go out and put the cameras bird watching
I'm not hunting I don't have a hunter's
license I don't need a hunting license
but uh and or if I'm just out there
looking for Sasquatch right these
cameras are used for all kinds of
purposes and this putting it in the
hunting regulations is only fixing a
part of the problem
so uh if you have any interest uh we
should talk on yeah putting a criminal
criminal side companion bill through
yeah thanks and um you know let's let's
think about that for next year there's
some things to check because we we have
done some legislation on drones and
other kinds of forms there is indeed and
Neil Kirk is here today yeah and I mean
I actually worked on many years ago when
I put in some drone legislation which we
passed um
worked with what trail cameras are not
drones yeah no I know I know but I'm
just saying I I think I I'd like to
check and see just where we're at now in
statute absolutely and if we're not
covered I you know I think that that's
something that probably does need to be
this in this in this times aren't they
absolutely thank you thank you
thank you very much
the chair will now call uh Robert
Johnson II who's in support of the bill
and has asked for three to four minutes
I'm gonna try to hold everybody to their
time if you don't mind
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee for the record Rob Johnson
representing the New Hampshire Farm
Bureau as a federation's policy director
and I do have written testimony that I
can provide to the committee but this
issue came about originally at least on
our side of the things was when House
Bill 490 was introduced last session and
that was relative to the use of
live-action game cameras which for those
of you that aren't aware
um the question was asked earlier about
that the 24 hours and fish and game
rules in within the rules it prohibits
the use of using that image within a
24-hour period I mean it's in rules not
in law and that's what this partially
does but it came about with the use of
the live action was was we didn't take a
position on that portion of the bill
that we it was we had landowners that
were surprised to learn
as I was in much of our leadership that
you did not need landowner permission to
place a a camera on private property so
at that hearing we requested this
potentially this requirement in in our
initial uh the information we provided
the committee was based on information
from a law in the state of Maine that
that requires land on permission as to
other states Wisconsin being another
um
I guess the one thing we'd like like you
to know and what we've worked on this
this language where the Timberland
owners has been stated earlier with with
Wildlife Federation and with fish and
game but we would like to make the
committee clear that uh you know we're
an organization that is uh includes many
devoted Hunters made up of people that
hunt and we strongly support we will
title is to defend the states long time
tradition of public access to private
land our members many are proud to to
have our lands used for recreational
purposes
uh
we just believe that it is a courtesy
and a landowner should have the right to
say no
uh if uh if somebody were to post a
camera more more often than not a
landowner is going to just want to know
that the cameras are there who put them
up where they are they may want to say
no I'm not over here but over here they
may want them taken down at a certain
time but uh you know in effect and I say
it in my letter that that a a camera
posted on private property without me as
a lender or knowing who put it up or
where it is it's a surveillance device
and it's as simple as that
and I'll I'll leave it at that Mr chair
in the interest of time thank you
thank you were there any questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
I will now call Diane Richardson uh who
opposes the bill and has asked for five
minutes and does have written testimony
oh and Sir if you want to hand your
testimony down uh to representative Ming
he'll make sure we all get a copy of it
and just for anybody who else who has
any uh we'll just follow the protocol of
putting it on the table here by
representative Ming and then he'll take
and make sure we all get a copy thank
you very much
hi my name is Diane Richardson I live in
the Lake Sunapee region I'm here to
testify against SB 14 as it's currently
written
I want to start by saying I absolutely
understand why this bill has come about
I know about several of the incidences
landowners have complained about and I
completely agree that no landowner
should be afraid to use their land for
fear being surveilled I also agree that
currently landowners do not have any way
of knowing if the cameras are owned by
hunters nature Watchers or criminals
while hunters and nature Watchers do not
want to get any humans on camera the
landowners don't always understand that
however I also believe
that this bill as written has several
potential problems and I'd really like
to see those results so we can reach an
agreeable compromise
this bill would require the labeling of
all cameras with the name and contact
information and as
previously mentioned that that could
allow the doxing and harassment of
Hunters by anti-hunters animal rights
activists and also the targeting of
Hunters by others who might have some
sort of a beef with somebody
this would increase property theft
vandalism as well as increase the odds
of a conflict in and out of the woods
a name on a camera could be potentially
dangerous a telephone number though oh
yeah I'm all for that
would change cell camera hunting
prohibition from the current same
calendar day to within 24 hours
this will effectively eliminate all
hunting in the areas with cell cameras
unless the hunter turns off transmission
more than 24 hours before hunting the
area
and will increase the enforcement
difficulty
it would require written permission for
the placement of any camera cell or
non-cell on any private land including
current use recreational
the exception listed is state-owned or
managed land
town or county-owned lands are not
listed as an exemption exception they
are not privately owned and they should
be accepted Exempted
current use recreational land tax
category is forbidden to restrict
hunting fishing or nature observation
cameras absolutely fit nature
observation
a lot of people that are not even
Hunters utilize game cameras there's an
entire social media groups dedicated to
such non-hunter game camera nature
photos
game cameras are definitely I'd argue
nature observation
landowners receive an additional 20
property tax discount for land enrolled
in the current use recreational tax
category with the agreement that the
land remain open for recreation
I quote if a landowner decides not to
post no trespassing and opens the
property to public use without an
entrance fee for 12 months of the year
the land is entitled to a 20 reduction
in the current use assessment of the
Acres open to public recreational use
to receive the additional 20
recreational adjustment the landowner
must allow all of the following
activities
hunting skiing fishing snowshoeing
hiking and nature observation
if any of these activities are
detrimental to a specific agriculture or
Forest crop that activity may be
prohibited if the 20 recreational
adjustment has been granted posting to
prohibit any activity requires the
approval of local assistance officials
end quote
additionally this law change will result
in much more land being posted
especially in the Southeast New
Hampshire
because landowners will get very tired
of being asked permission and will just
post the land to stop the phone calls
and door knocking
Southeast New Hampshire has literally
hundreds of cameras out there that would
now need permission slips
my ideas for compromise are all cameras
labeled clearly with a valid working
telephone number only
or hunting license
written permission for any camera within
300 feet of a building occupied or not
as well as livestock Corrals fenced
pasture active vegetable Gardener
Orchard regardless of the tax category
written permission for any cellular
camera on land not in current use
recreational
town or Camp County lands are not
privately owned and should be Exempted
from needing written permission
change the cell camera portion back to
same calendar day as currently or
alternatively simply ban cell cameras
use during open bear and deer season if
enforcement has been proving to be an
issue
and current use Tech recreational tax
category landowners may not restrict
camera nor require written permission
for those that would put it on the
hunter or the nature Watcher to go to
the town clerk and confirm current use
recreational status as none of the phone
applications provide that tax category
info thank you so much
thank you for your testimony are there
any questions
oh did you have written testimony to
pass around
hand that over I don't see any questions
for you so thank you so so much for your
testimony
the chair will put on his glasses and
call Dennis Ward who is supporting the
bill and needs five minutes
if you can keep it to your time or
slightly less that'd be appreciated
thank you very much
thank you for having me I probably won't
need five minutes I I just overstate
just in case uh for the record I am
Dennis Ward I'm a retired Dairy Farmer
from up in Northern New Hampshire Monroe
New Hampshire actually
I own some parcels of land that Hunters
hunt on my Farm's been in my family for
more than 200 years and and uh
um to be honest I I have really good
rapport with all the hunters up there
that hunt my property uh some of them
and probably most of them come to me and
say I'm going to hunt on your land do
you mind and I totally appreciate it uh
my wife my family and I and and my
brothers sisters all of us walked the
woods on my property on property they
all own
um quite a bit one weekend we're getting
a little older so we don't so much
anymore but but I would be very
distressed if I got up there and found
game cameras uh that I didn't know were
there I have never posted my property
because the hunters have been good they
come ask me or or I've had Hunters say I
got a deer up on yours you want to slice
of meat or something and and uh
so I'm happy to have people out there we
have a lot that's almost 100 acres and
and we went to the school and said use
it for your kids they've taken the
students up there they've built a
three-sided shelter
um out of trees from up there that they
cut they do outdoor classes up there
they even have had some of their classes
go up on a weekend and stay overnight
we're happy to have people use it but
um
my mindset and and it's similar to those
that I talk to is that this is my
property I I do the upkeep on it I log
it as uh conservatively and as
conscious of the environment as I can
and and
I think if somebody wants to use the
property that I'm caring for they should
let me know and I've had people say to
me they were surprised that it wasn't
already a law that they had to get
permission to put something like game
cameras up there it's the same with the
tree stands people whether they injure a
tree or not people think that they ought
to asked the owner first
but anyway I support this most of the
people the landowners that I talk to up
in Northern New Hampshire support this
um so appreciate your no I I would like
to talk to one point there's some been
some suggestions of changes I don't
think you can make this perfect
you can have 18 pages of legislation to
get all of the details that might be
missed but I think we have to trust and
understand that that you need to get the
basic concept down and and I think fish
and game is is been very good they've
um I don't remember if it was fish and
game or the police department but one or
the other has been to me and said hey
we're going to do something involves
your property and I don't remember what
it was for now but but fish and game is
very good at unless they have to keep it
secret they talk to the landowners and
and let them know what they're doing so
that's not an issue as far as I'm
concerned but anyway thank you thank you
for your testimony are there any
questions
representative Smith
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question based on your
testimony it sounds like you have a
great working relationship with the
hunters that come to your land is that
correct I do yes so then if you have
this great relationship now how is this
bill going to make it better
um
well
I'm a bit conservative and I watch
what's happening in government
Nationwide not as much in New Hampshire
but Nationwide and some in New Hampshire
and there's so much creep into the
rights of of property owners I'm
concerned about it you you allow Hunters
without getting permission now
even nature people that are looking at
nature this is fine it's not a big deal
but when does it move to uh somebody
spying on me or trying to find out what
I'm doing that I shouldn't be doing or
whatever I you know I just I think it's
a courtesy to let the landowner know
thank you for your testimony any further
questions
seeing none thank you
the chair now recognizes and calls Neil
Kirk
supports the bill and asks for two
minutes
thank you Mr chairman for the record I'm
Neil Kirk I live in Ware and I'm
representing myself
this bill is very important because of
its privacy aspect
one of the reasons why folks keep their
land open and don't post it is because
they have no problem with Hunters bird
watchers and everyone else coming on
their land and doing things
if you change that
accuse me if technology changes that
and so without further legislation
anyone coming on my property or a
property can put up a camera and see
what I'm doing with my wife or whatever
I happen to be doing with my friends and
Neighbors when we walk the property
I'm going to have an adverse reaction to
that
I don't want what I'm doing to be
available for some public sitting in the
in a bar somewhere watching it
at their convenience it's
it's just not the kind of thing that I
expected so
I'm going to take Ria I'm going to react
to that retroactively you're changing
the rules so I'm going to take my land
out of conservation status I'm not going
to put my land into conservation status
I'm going to post my land
you will find that the available land
for hunting and bird watching decreases
immediately by those people who are
upset that retroactively after they've
done expecting done put their land into
conservation expecting certain things
find out that's not the case technology
has changed the way we do things and the
legislature is an obligation to make
sure
that we protect those people who have
expectations of privacy on their own
property even when they open it up to
others not expecting to be spied on
I don't know how you deal with some of
the other issues in this bill it's not
it's not my area of expertise but I
think the chairman was right when he
suggested before that not only should
this issue cover Hunters but it should
cover other people accessing that
property who are not Hunters
to protect the privacy of the landowner
now some landowners may not care and
that's fine
but the point is that you give people
the option to say yes I accept these
cameras on my property or I don't and
not be surprised when they're out with
their honey necking in the woods so to
speak finding their own candid camera
and everybody in the local bar room is
laughing at them
this is a very important bill from a
privacy point of view and I hope you
folks will do the right thing thank you
Mr chairman
thank you rep former representative and
The Honorable Neil Kirk it's good to see
you again and it's good to hear that
you're still out necking in the woods
with your wife
I'm not sure that she'll appreciate the
fact I've made that public but
nonetheless yes
representative Smith you're recognized
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question I'm just going off
quick my own personal memory
um game cameras have been around
probably 30 years with film meaning I
remember back in the day I would have to
go in swap the film out and get it
developed to get pictures digital
cameras probably been around about 20
years where you just take the SD card
out live action cameras I think have
been around maybe 10 years
so this technology in many forms has
been around for almost 30 years and it
has transformed to what we see today
with these live action cameras but the
point is what has changed over the last
10 years that these cameras have been
around the live action ones and today
thank you for the question very simply
the price has gone down and everybody
can have these simple as that the fact
that technology is very expensive means
that it's not readily available when it
becomes cheap it's readily available
everybody uses it and that's the reason
for the problem today
thank you and get a representative Brown
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question can you explain for
me a little bit what you mean by uh
retroactively that this this changes
retroactively the way the law was can
you just clarify for me thank you I
probably I shouldn't have used the word
changes the law retroactively but it
changes how the law Works retroactively
representative goalie
thank you Mr chairman
honorable Kirk welcome good to see you
sir
undercurrent use currently allows folks
to have access to land open access to
land
do you believe that under those current
use laws and having the ability to have
open access to land gives you a right
to surveil that property of another
individual
personally no and I think that's the
issue before the uh the house with this
particular bill
um
I think
especially in New Hampshire where we're
pretty individualistic and protect our
own privacy rights look at that recent
Constitutional Amendment that passed
with 81 percent of the vote
um we expect certain things and when
those expectations don't come about
we react
and one of the things we expect is that
when we open our property to others
they're going to go there look at it
ride horses whatever they're going to do
but they're not going to do the kinds of
things we don't expect them to do and
that includes surveillance unintentional
or intentional we just don't expect that
and I think to the extent that that is
now possible and apparently legal
possible in terms of economics legal in
terms of the fact that apparently it's
not prohibited by law I think folks in
New Hampshire look to the legislature to
protect them to to resolve that issue
that's what this bill does
thank you representative are there any
further questions
representative Smith thank you Mr
chairman thank you again for my uh
taking my question
in an open public area there is no
expectation of privacy that's that's
fact that's law meaning you're walking
through the woods you're in a parking
lot you're in a public space here
there's no expectation of privacy so I
hear this talk about privacy privacy
privacy these game cameras are invading
privacy but in reality they're in open
space they're in an area where if I want
to go with my telephoto camera take
pictures I'm free to do so I don't see
the difference here
between open space whether it's a live
action camera or someone with a cell
phone camera
thank you for that question I I do see a
distinction the kinds of spaces that
you're talking about are so-called quote
public spaces unquote the street
the public Courthouse
what we're talking about here is private
property
and I think the expectations of privacy
are very different for that even where
private property is by the landowners
action or inaction open to the public I
see a very great distinction between
those two situations
thank you any further questions
seeing none thank you thank you Mr
chairman and thank you members of the
committee
the chair will now call
Nick
Spader
okay
I knew it wasn't SpongeBob
so my name is Nick spadero I live in
Ware uh thank you for taking my
statement
I see a couple of additional issues with
this bill
um ones that Diane uh didn't mention she
did a good job of listing a lot of them
my first one is that no one mentioned
what the fee is if you are caught with a
game camera and the fee as listed in the
bill is a thousand dollars per offense
and to me that's pretty harsh if this
bill passes it goes into effect 60 days
after it passes and so some people like
me have dozens of cameras out in the
woods and I'm gonna have to do a Mad
Dash to try to remember and find every
single one of them and if I miss a
couple and my name and phone number is
already on my game camera I'm gonna get
a call from fish and game and I could be
in for thousands of dollars and to me
when you can do a lot of things
illegally in the woods
um hunting things out of season poaching
the wrong gender of animal it this fee
schedule just doesn't fit with
everything else
a couple years ago I shot a male turkey
which is referred to as a Tom And
there's a female turkey in the grass
next to him and I didn't see her in two
of my pellets from my shotgun struck her
in the head and unfortunately killed her
so I called fish and game they came down
and gave me a 200 fee and took the bird
and I thought 200 was a little excessive
for my first offense and an honest
mistake and so to charge people a
thousand dollars for a game camera when
people have dozens out there could be
excessive in my opinion
the other thing that's not mentioned and
I do sympathize with folks landowners
I'm a landowner myself that thought that
this was already the law uh it makes
sense when you when you first hear it
that it would be law but I'm going to
list the states that do not require
permission to place a game camera on
private land Massachusetts does not
require Vermont does not require Rhode
Island does not require New Jersey does
not require a New York does not require
it Connecticut does not require it so I
don't think that the great state of New
Hampshire should be in a club with all
those other states and have more
restrictive game camera access than
States like New York Massachusetts
Jersey and Connecticut
thank you are there any questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today
chair now calls Chris Fife
who's asked for three to five minutes
and supports the bill and does have
written testimony so if you could just
leave that over there for representative
Ming that would be fantastic and thank
you representative Ming for taking the
handouts
good morning chairman committee uh my
name is Chris Fife I'm public affairs
manager for warehouser and I'm also
currently the president of the New
Hampshire Timberland Owners Association
I'm also a hunter and a small landowner
myself and I'm speaking today on behalf
of warehouser
uh I have much of what I'm going to say
in the written comments that I'm passing
around uh those apply to both SB 14 and
15 so I will just focus on SB 14 right
now
warehouser owns approximately 24 000
acres in cost County in the towns of
Arrow Dumber Cambridge and Wentworth
location this is part of our overall New
England Timberland ownership in Maine
New Hampshire and Vermont our forest
management is certified under the
sustainable forestry initiative or SFI
and additionally our New Hampshire
Timberlands are managed under a working
for us conservation easement ensuring
that the land will be managed for Timber
will not be developed and will remain
open to the public for snowmobiling
dispersed Recreation and including
hunting
we recognize that New Hampshire has a
rich hunting tradition and Heritage
that's underpinned by Hunter's respect
for private landowners who allow them to
access to conduct private property
warehouser recognizes that this
tradition supports sound game management
as well as important recreational
economies in the small communities Where
We own land
we welcome hunting and fishing and other
dispersed Recreation on our property and
strive to maintain a relationship of
mutual respect with Hunters
these users are often the first ones to
alert us if there are any issues out on
the land and that's important to us they
act as another set of eyes when we don't
have our own Foresters in an area
on a routine basis
foreign
game cameras however aren't really an
essential part of New Hampshire's
hunting tradition in fact they're
relatively new technology that can
conduct surveillance of a landowner's
property without landowners knowledge
I know we this was addressed to the
committee and I would agree with the uh
the comments that were made prior to my
what I said about the technology and the
price of the technology recognizing that
it has been out for a while but the the
price is such now that really any hunter
can can get a hold of game camera and
put those out
landowners don't have any opportunity to
view the images or the data captured by
the cameras and usually no knowledge of
where the cameras are placed so sb14's
requirement for permission to place the
game camera on private properties kind
is a common sense step really respecting
landowners rights while maintaining New
Hampshire's hunting tradition
when a hunter contacts us asking
permission to place a game camera it
provides an opportunity for us to ensure
that we do not have operational plans
for that location this communication
helps us to avoid conflict and to
provide a safe experience for the hunter
for loggers and for our Foresters
I know that I'm speaking for many of the
other large landowners and managers in
Northern New Hampshire when I say that
sb14 will strengthen New Hampshire's
hunting tradition encouraging landowners
to continue to generously share their
land with recreational users a practice
that benefits our local communities and
the state
so as a New Hampshire Timberland owner
warehouser respectfully urges the
committee to pass SB 14 as presented
and if I could I would just like to say
a couple of things
just to make the point that this bill
this law would not only apply to Hunters
as I understand it but to anybody who
puts a game camera in the woods and I
don't know if littering falls under fish
and game laws and I didn't have a chance
to look at that but I will say that the
forest rangers and the wardens are
always very helpful and responsive to
landowners to us as a landowner if we
have issues with littering in helping us
figure that out so they act as
the uh they their law enforcement
capabilities help us on issues Beyond
just straight forestry issues or fish
and game issues and I so I think the
game camera being put out whether it's
put out by someone specifically for
hunting or for another purpose would
still they would still be our go-to for
the first point of contact if we had a
question about that
uh
we also would be very interested in
helping any hunter who was being
harassed in working with Fish and Game
to pursue whoever was doing the
harassment uh in whatever method was
necessary to to prevent that it's very
important to us that Hunters can still
use our property that that tradition is
upheld and you know we would see that as
a real affront to that tradition and and
just frankly to common decency and
respect for hunters out on that property
so
I don't think the name and the the
requirements of a name and a phone
number should be a concern here and it
would be very helpful to the landowner
in being able to communicate with the
owner of the camera so I thank you for
your time and I'd be happy to answer any
questions if there are any
thank you are there any questions
representative Smith thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question I want to thank you for you
wirehousers 24 000 acres and behalf of
the people keeping it open for hunting
because that's an incredible amount of
land
um don't you think this will be a
logistical nightmare for
owning so much land you theoretically
could get bombarded with thousands of
requests from hunters for permission to
place cameras on your land how would you
go about implementing something such a
great magnitude thank you for that
question yeah that's certainly something
that when we first read this bill was
one of our bigger questions and I think
the provision in here to be able to post
to allow cameras if that comes to be if
we find there's a huge number of
requests that would be an option we
could take my experience in working with
the land base in New Hampshire is that
I would anticipate I would be surprised
if there were more than a dozen or so
requests for this
so that's something we'll have to see as
this plays out but I think the knowing
whose camera it is that that is more
important to us at this point and and
having people request permission then
the next step for us would be figuring
out if we need to do go the posting
thank you any other questions
uh representative Brown
thank you uh Mr chair uh and thank you
taking my question you bring up an
interesting point and I'm mentioning
this just so maybe we can when the
colonel comes up we can talk about this
later
uh were you saying if I understood you
correctly because of the definition of
game camera as it's put in this law
which has any device capable of
recording etc etc
that you would read that to say it
covers
any situation where someone so the
fishing game this large efficient game
would then cover
anyone that puts a camera that fits this
definition
regardless of why they're putting it out
there I think I think that's what you
said if I if I even made that even
partially clear I'm sorry
maybe the current will kind of address
that later but thank you yeah that's a
good point I think
I think I probably was not clear in in
stating that either because I'm
certainly not an expert on that but I
guess the point I will make is that fish
and game is often the one that we as a
landowner will go to first because they
do represent they and the four strangers
represent the law enforcement that deals
with issues on Forest land especially in
the North country and so uh I've I
appreciate you following up and I'll be
very interested to hear the Colonel's
response to that as well
any further questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
the chair calls Walter Lacy uh so
supports the bill and has asked for two
minutes
I've discovered a in a hearing issue and
a setting like this and I
appreciate your patience
I am Walter Lacy from Keene and my wife
and I own 650 acres of land in Keene
Swansea and Chesterfield
although not a hunter myself I believe
very strongly in traditional uses of the
land and hunting is certainly one of
them
our land has always been open to hunting
and trapping I can't imagine that
changing
that being said I have had a problem
with tree stands over the years twice
associated with game cameras in two
instances healthy valuable oak trees are
damaged none of the stands or cameras
had contact information on them and all
my efforts to communicate with the
owners by leaving my contact information
on flagging tape
was unsuccessful
in the most recent isn't it because of
the nature of the camera involved a fish
and game officer was able to identify
the offender
the mutual benefits of having contact
information on this equipment seem
undeniable
a simple phone call could clear up any
question a landowner might have and a
hunter might get back a misplaced stand
or camera
the increasing use and sophistication of
game cameras should require permission
for their use on private land
the idea that something is allowed in my
backyard
but not yours is unacceptable
it all seems to me a matter of common
courtesy
if you want to leave a piece of gear on
someone else's land
you get permission put your name on it
what could be simple than that
I don't like to see land posted I think
it's a short-sighted measure
if the common sense requirements of
Senate bill is 14 and 15 are not enacted
however
I'm afraid land owners may be left with
no other choice
with privileges
comes
I understand I think you hit the button
for the mic with your hand when you were
there we go
I got the impression that you were also
talking about the the next bill as well
so uh if do you have written copies of
that I do yes okay if you could hand
that down we will consider it for both
and thank you very much for your time
are there any questions
seeing none thank you very much make
sure you pass a copy down to or your
pile of copies down to 100 of Ming
chair now calls
Chuck salty
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is
Chuck Souther my wife Diane and I own a
farm here in Concord
um
I want to say that we love Hunters we
have numerous Hunters that utilize the
property we do ask however that they
have permission
and we do this because we are in a large
part a pick your own Farm
and open to the public we encourage our
customers to not only do the pick your
own thing but spend some time on the
farm bring a picnic lunch go down in the
hay Fields walk through the woods on our
trails
um so that that's all part of what we do
and we think that they have a reasonable
right to expect that they're not under
surveillance doing that when we give
permission to the hunters and when we
one of the reasons we do that is to make
sure that the hunters we get permission
to understand that there will be members
of the public on those Trails
specifically on weekends
but also to find out a little bit more
about what they're doing while they're
out there the same goes for for tree
stands when this all came up I was kind
of surprised as I think a lot of
landowners were to find out that we
can't remove cameras that we don't know
who put them there or why
um that just seems wrong to me you know
on my own property and what I kind of go
back to when all this is when I was a
teenager and my father and uncles taught
me how to hunt and when I took Hunter
education which I'm thinking about it
here seeing was more than 50 years ago
the thing that I remember the most was
responsibility responsibility
responsibility for when you go on
somebody else's property you're
responsible for your actions you're
responsible for your bullet responsible
for everything it just seems to me that
that's what this really comes down to is
it not unreasonable to ask somebody
that's going to do something on your
property to ask permission
that's just basic responsibility we went
through this several years ago with the
arrow issue it's not doesn't seem to be
a problem now to put names and addresses
on their arrows so that we don't find
them in our hay and my Dairy farming
friends don't find it in their silage so
that's what this kind of came down to I
support the bill and I hope that you can
pass it thank you thank you sir are
there any questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today you have written testimony please
pass it to representative Ming if there
aren't enough copies the clerk will make
copies for the committee
the chair calls Stephen wood who
supports the bill and has asked for
three minutes
go ahead
I'm gonna keep that gentleman dancing
thank you for the opportunity to speak
to you I am Stephen wood uh I and my
family own about 900 and some odd acres
in Lebanon in Plainfield and we manage
poverty Lane Orchards and Farnam
hillsiders there
um and we post our land and I have just
handed around uh signs of our of our
about copies of our signs we we welcome
hunters and always have
but we want them to show us the respect
of asking permission pretty
straightforward we have had a wonderful
relationship with Hunters therefore
um and I suppose I could have brought
you great big stacks of the permissions
that we've handed out but
um we always have a lot of hunters on
the land
we also sometimes have to close part of
our land because we like Chuck Souther
have a pick your own Orchard we have
walked through the woods this year we
closed a couple hundred acres until
Thanksgiving
not a single Hunter complaint even
people were accustomed to hunt there
they had another several hundred acres
of land to hold on and they where they
knew they were welcome
um but also the one of the good things
about these this relationship is they
will encourage other Hunters to ask
permission it seems to me New Hampshire
has a long history of of supporting the
writers rights of hunters which we
support as well
but also of profound respect for private
property and for personal
privacy
this bill is about all of those things
and it's also Chuck Souther was speaking
of respect it's about that and common
courtesy civility
we own this land we pay taxes on this
land we care for this land
and it is not very difficult to ask us
permission it's very rare for us to deny
permission there has to be something
pretty egregious for for us to say no
um but we also find that as I say the
hunters we don't police Our Land The
Hunters police the land the hunters tell
us where there are stands that that that
don't have names on them how to sell us
that there are people parking where they
shouldn't be parking and you know yes
those very welcoming signs we've passed
around uh which basically say you're
welcome to use this land just please ask
permission for a few things
some of them wind up on the ground with
bullets in them you know or Tires over
them the hunters usually put them back
up
because we have developed this respect
for relationship but it is founded in
part on the courtesy of them respecting
our private property rights and asking
permission this bill seems to be an
absolutely sensible extension of that in
the modern world
um and if we start finding that we
can't insist on that
we'll have one alternative which is to
take those very friendly yellow signs
down
make a phone call and order hundreds of
bright red no trespassing signs that's
about the last thing we want to do and
the people who've said if if you don't
move forward with this sort of
legislation you're going to see more
land posted to all of our detriment I
think are right
so I vigorously urge you to support this
bill
thank you for for your patience and
attention thank you sir
there any questions
representative Smith thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question it appears you have an
incredible system there of Hunter access
a good system of cooperation no problems
uh according to your testimony so why
would a bill like this be needed based
upon the system that you have that's in
place that seems to work so well a bill
like this is needed sir because of what
others have said which is that which is
that the people people don't know how to
act and this stuff is very well
available to all sorts of people
and if you don't
I just I I want to make sure people know
I I don't want to spend the money to go
put something like game cameras uh take
our signs down and add a line about game
cameras I want to just be able to rely
on people asking permission and getting
other people to ask permission
this law would
I agree if you're implying that it's a
Pity that we were we need this sort of
clarity in law now but I'm afraid I
think we do need this sort of clarity
alone now so it's not going to improve
on our circumstance with Hunters it's
doing just going to further clarify the
circumstance the deal
and it's not a system it's just our
communicating with with the people who
are welcome to use our land what our
expectations are and they're behaving
accordingly I mean I guess that's a
system I don't know I don't think I
don't think this is a systems engineer I
just made a welcoming sign quite a lot
we've had those signs up for
25 years or something so
thank you sir representative goalie
thank you Mr chair thank you for coming
and testifying yes sir
seeing you requiring permission for
hunting on your properties do you get
overwhelmed with calls or is it just an
appreciative thing to understand who's
on your property
we don't get overwhelmed with calls
um and
I remembered again we're in Lebanon in
Plainfield
um I remember a day when I thought we
might be getting overwhelmed with
hudders
um
but uh
you know I'm not sure where the edge of
overwhelmed is with all that land I'm
perfectly comfortable giving
the 20 or 30 people who ask permission
we usually have discussions about where
other people are hunting
um and as I say we we asked them not to
go certain places during periods
but uh but no I mean I
um I suppose if we got overwhelmed
um if it became a real profound nuisance
we'd have to rethink but we've never had
to rethink I mean we've got I've got
this stack of files I don't know why we
even keep the files but we you know we
have it
it's not like perforated we they fill
out the whole thing and we keep one part
and they take one part that says they
have permission to hunt on our land and
ours says what their license number and
name and phone number and contact info
is and that's that and like their their
hunting license number as well
and we get out of state Hunters as well
I'm on occasion I mean if yeah okay
here's a denial
seven guys show up from Massachusetts
well seven guys show up from anywhere
one of them's looking a little bit tight
and they all want to go out and Hunt
together
not today sir you know I mean we don't
we'll drop we don't let huge parties of
people hunt together but that's out of
respect to the other Hunters as much as
anything else and also to our neighbors
and you know whatever
thank you sir
uh representative Khan
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question is it possible that
uh only few property owners have their
telephone number written in the property
that's why no not too many Hunters can
reach out to the property owners I
thought it was required on a well
actually of course it's only required if
you're posting your land
um I don't know I mean it's a it's an
easy matter of record to find out who
owns a piece of land all the the the
town databases they've all got I mean
the property property maps are pretty
good now technology is pretty good on
that now you can you can you can find a
landowner quite easily so sorry but I
don't know the answer to that question
sir follow-up Mr chairman follow-up I
just want to make this uh not a question
but a statement that I have full support
of your ownership of your property and
your rights
I think that's very kind of you to say
so thank you
any further questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you for your attention
the chair will now call Joyce Brady who
supports the bill and has asked for two
minutes
if you could please stay to your time
that'd be great
thank you Mr chairman for the record
Joyce Brady I'm New Hampshire Farm
Bureau president I'm a landowner and I'm
a farmer
the unfortunate thing of testifying near
the end is everybody's already said
everything
that could be a good thing right so now
I have other things to say
um New Hampshire is a very unique State
there's very few States and I'm I
apologize I don't know exactly how many
that give the privilege of hunting as
long as the land's not posted
so when the gentleman had had testified
that our neighboring states don't
require permission for cameras he forgot
to mention that they all require written
permission to hunt
anytime
so a lot of states you have to have
written permission to hunt
anytime anywhere so New Hampshire
allows a very unique privilege to
Hunters
the landowners in New Hampshire have the
right to make a decision do they want to
allow these Hunters
or do they not they post their land or
they don't if they're in current use
there are other ways
um to have restrictions
um
but it's the landowner's right to make
that decision
as a hunter having a privilege
you need to respect
the owner the land you need to
appreciate that privilege and out of
appreciation and maybe it's just because
I grew up
many years you know I'm one of the old
school people now I hate to say that but
I am and it's about appreciation it's
about respect common courtesy we have
seen more and more people moving up to
our state with a different mindset I
think that's part of the problem between
the cheaper cameras and everybody has
access to them
along with just a different mindset and
we need to protect our landowners and
give them the rights that they have
through paying their taxes in their
mortgage to say yes or no to cameras and
let the hunter
appreciate their privilege
by making them at it's actually a sad
day that they're we're here testifying
asking Allah to be passed
to make Hunters understand that they
have a privilege and they should
appreciate it
thank you any questions
seeing none thank you for your time
today
chair calls Kyle Baker who supports the
bills and asked for two minutes
if you could please keep it to two
minutes
uh good morning Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Kyle Baker I am
here representing New Hampshire Wildlife
Federation Hampshire Wildlife Federation
is a Statewide Association that
represents
protecting the right to hunt fish and
trap in New Hampshire as well as the
protection of the access to land to hunt
fish and trap on represent approximately
55 different fish and game clubs as well
as an Affiliated membership of about 50
000 Sports men and women around the
state and we are in support of this bill
we see this as a great a balance strikes
the right balance between protecting the
ability to continue the traditional open
land use policies in New Hampshire as
well as protecting and honoring and
respecting the privilege of the use of
private land I forgot to bring the math
math with me today but for every you
know the math works out to roughly every
acre that's owned and managed by the
state these guys in the back of the room
here they manage about a hundred
um so it's incredibly important to
Sportsmen around the state that these
lands remain active and open for all
recreational uses including Hunting
Fishing and trapping
um when we originally
um started talking about this bill we
went down and we met with folks in the
timber Timberland owners well the Farm
Bureau and listening to the personal
stories that these folks have had about
negative interactions with you know you
know these guys will be the first person
to tell you that 99 of the hunters are
great but it's always the one percent
um that they have some trouble with so
we see this bill as a great balance game
cameras are great piece of technology
um when you're looking to recruit Young
Folks into hunting a game camera is a
great way to do it nothing gets a kid
more excited than seeing the bear the
deer on the camera and saying this is
what's going on in the woods near your
home so we want to we encourage uh you
know the technology but at the same time
we respect the need for the balance with
landowner respect so uh with that I'm
happy to answer any questions that folks
might have thank you sir any questions
representative Brown thank you Mr
chairman
um
okay any questions
no okay uh thank you for your testimony
the chair calls Dan dokum who supports
the bill and has asked for two minutes
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee uh I'm here to represent
myself my name is Dan dockham I live in
the town of Gilmanton and I'm a lifelong
resident of Belknap County
um as a farmer small time if I'm a hobby
farmer and a sportsman hunter fisher
trapping and all of that
um
I support the bill
and in talking with
family neighbors friends as well as
other Sportsmen and whatever is what's
kind of helped me form my opinion I have
to this day not had
any abuse but one thing that has gotten
my concern is and you've heard it over
and over privacy
I have a driveway that's a half a mile
long off of a back road it's dead end
nobody goes by the house or anything
else on that driveway there's two very
good deer Crossings
and I don't mind people using for
hunting but one of my big concerns is if
somebody wants to rob me rip off I a lot
of equipment is not on the lock and key
or whatever and they can set up the
cameras and find out when me and my wife
leave when we return and then go help
themselves
other than that I guess pretty much
everything has been said as a sportsman
I believe we owe the other landowners
the courtesy of uh getting permission
and I appreciate the privilege that they
provide for me
um
I'll be glad tried to answer any
questions if anybody has anything thank
you sir thank you for coming in today
and testifying do we have any questions
seeing none thank you so much very good
thank you for hearing me out a chair
calls Jason stock
who was representing the New Hampshire
Timberland Owners Association he's asked
for three minutes he does have written
testimony
and Jason as I do with a lot of people
who testify professionally I'll tell you
if you've got the written testimony
please try not to read from it thank you
thank you it's actually not my testimony
it's testimony
you can explain it when you're at the
mic
still get used to the microphone thing
well good morning for the for the record
my name is Jason stock I'm the executive
director of the New Hampshire Timberland
Owners Association and
I apologize that the testimony that I'm
be PR that I am providing is from a
number of members that have sent me
emails and letters and asked me to
forward them they did have some some
email bounces and things of that nature
and they just said hey Belton suspenders
if you could just take it with you when
you go Tuesday morning please do so but
again uh Jason stock New Hampshire
Timberland Owners Association I I
truly appreciate the opportunity to
speak in support of this bill our our
membership
we represent Timberland owners in the
state's Forest products industry we have
approximately 1300 members who own and
or manage about a million acres of land
in the state of New Hampshire
um and much of it is actually open to
hunting we support traditional
traditional hunting Wildlife managements
a big part of healthy Forest talk to any
land manager who's trying to manage an
area trying to manage a hardwood stand
in an area with a high dense moose
populations they will be pulling their
hair out telling you I can't get any
regeneration because that darn moose
just keeps coming through and mowing my
sugar maple and Yellow Birch saplings
um so we we support hunting our members
are are
really involved in hunting personally I
am as well I hunt
um but what I want to say is this Bill
yes it's about game cameras but and I
think you've heard about this this is
about privacy you heard the terms common
courtesy respect
um
what we're talking about here is putting
a device on someone's piece of property
that takes an image or a video and in
some cases can send it anywhere
and if you think about that if I have a
piece of property and someone's out
taking images and then without my cons
without my knowledge
that to me is invasive and you know as a
landowner and as someone who's who owns
property you know I should at least have
the courtesy of saying you know
put if you're going to put a camera up
great just put it on the back 40 or put
it over here this is an area that I use
with my family I hike with my grandkids
Etc so I for us this is a this is a
personal property issue this is a it's a
property rights issue and you've heard
from landowners today of all size
ownerships Geographic this isn't just a
Sullivan County issue this isn't just a
koas county issue you heard it from
landowners from across the state
um as the price of cameras have come
down they have Pro there are more out
there on the landscape and so that is
that is kind of what has brought us here
is you know this proliferation of these
cameras
people own land for a lot of different
reasons
um they own it as an investment they own
it for recreation they own it as a
buffer from Neighbors or it is an
extension of their their home property
and they own it for Solitude and in some
cases some of our members they own it
for work I may be a logger and I may go
out and buy a couple thousand acres
because that's where I'm going to work
this next winter that's that's kind of
why I own why I would buy it
um and so
this notion about privacy and rights of
privacy I wanted to touch on that
because people own land for different
reasons there are also parts of that
property that may be on the back 40 that
are particularly special I have I've
been on I've had the benefit of being
with many of my members well they'll
take go for a walk in their forest and
they'll take you to an area this is a
really this is a really special spot
this is where my grandfathers my
father's ashes are
or this is a lookout this is where I
propose to my wife what have you and
these are areas on people's property
that really mean something to them and
so the thought of having a camera placed
there without their knowledge is really
kind of an affront to them and they say
you know you know this is it just isn't
right
ask for permission and I can say yeah
don't put it on that the corner by the
the stone wall in the old apple tree
that's an area that's special to me in
my family and so you know it was
suggested earlier in some of the earlier
testimony that well maybe you just do a
300 foot buffer area well that doesn't
cover those types of situations it just
doesn't work
um
and again as I mentioned I've had
members call and
you know as I've heard from our members
in there are a lot of members that'll
say you know this is a privacy if I have
children
um and I have children you know that I
take out on the property or my grandkids
I don't want potentially an image kind
of going out and who knows where um and
so that's that's an issue
um the other piece is in you know these
cameras when we conducted Timber sale
they're out there on the property and
you'll have Foresters or loggers come
along and they're getting ready they're
marking the wood they're setting laying
out the sale and here's a camera
now what if there isn't if it isn't
labeled what do I do with it we've been
told by New Hampshire Fish and Game
department that's private property don't
take it down
well I'm trying to I'm trying to work
here trying to get a job done you know
and I'm told not to take it down I don't
know who to contact I feel like I'm in a
catch-22 I call fishing game I'm sure
they'll come out and take it but as I
think we heard earlier you know there's
people have many cameras as I think I
heard earlier in earlier testimony
dozens of cameras and I may miss one or
I may forget where I put them I've heard
from some hunting guides they'll put out
dozens and dozens of cameras and it's
part of their business and that's great
and that's fine but again at least give
me the courtesy or give me the option to
say look
where are you putting them I'd like to
have some say in that and let's keep
track of them so that if I'm going to
lay out and harvest in a particular unit
I know all right it's time to get the
cameras out of that unit because we're
going to go go do a harvest
um
the last couple items I I want to just
touch on is there was a question about
contacting Property Owners you had had
that conversation earlier about the
signage for Mr wood
anyone that hunts the these days you're
probably familiar there are programs
called Onyx and some of these other
programs that are very good in helping
identify who the landowner is so there
is technology and of course there's the
good old-fashioned go to the town hall
and pull up a tax card
so there are ways to contact the
landowner if you do want to find out
okay who do I who do I contact if I want
to put a put a camera out
um the issue about being inundated or
over overrun by request
um when this issue came up before the
nhtoa two years ago it was a year ago
two years ago we had a very lengthy
discussion about that issue and we feel
that the posting the posting on the uh
on the signage that posting paragraph
saying we allow cameras we feel that
sufficiently addresses it
um and that actually that suggestion
came from one of our very large
landowners up in the northern part of
the state he says I don't want my
Foresters having to field hundreds of
calls or dozens of calls is I just don't
it's not an issue great we'll just put a
sign up cameras permitted good you're
good to go
lastly you know current use it's been
raised in the recreational discount
current use
we're assessing land on its productive
capability there is a there is an
additional incentive to keep your land
open for Passive Recreation
and pedestrian Recreation on on property
um
again as I go back to the the what I had
started with the ins you know installing
cameras to me is not passive Recreation
um it just isn't passive Recreation and
I would I would argue and contend that
again just ask I think people will be
very surprised that most landowners
happy to let you put it out there just
let me know where where it's going to go
um with that I'll conclude my my
testimony and I'll be happy to answer
any questions thank you sir are there
any questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you and the last card for the day
Colonel Jordan
you've asked for five minutes
thank you much I think people want lunch
yes I certainly would join that uh if
you're buying Mr chairman
he didn't say yes so I guess we're going
to be buying my own
um so I view this already as a success
because quite frankly first of all I
want to start by thanking before I
forget it thanking every landowner in
here today uh who's come to testify you
know who continually allows us a
sportsman the chairman is the the vice
chair is I know and maybe many more of
you I certainly am for the opportunity
to hunt on your property I think it's
incredibly generous of you
um and I just want to thank you for that
so and that brings me to why this bill
was born so this is a piece of success
because we were able to get uh the
Timberlands Association landowners Farm
Bureau and sportsman through the
Wildlife Federation which represents the
largest group of Sportsmen in the state
all together in agreement that something
needs to be done and so the effort there
was a lot of effort put forth to balance
the rights of both the landowner which
is important to me and I'll tell you why
in a minute and the Sportsman which is
important to me because I am one so I
didn't want this to be an
anti-sportsman's bill and I certainly
didn't want it to throw landowners out
of current use I think moving to that
step is a mistake I think that's what's
happened in our western states there are
a lot of western states where you can't
hunt you can be shot for being on
properties which we're very lucky in New
Hampshire we don't have that we're a
permissive State I'd like to do whatever
I can while I'm here to make sure that
continues the number one complaint I get
in the fall the number one complaint and
it's been going this way for a couple of
years now is cameras and tree stands it
is the number one complaint of
landowners landowners are shocked when
they call me and they say listen I found
a bunch of cameras on my my lawn or my
land and no one asked me permission for
that and I tell them well they don't
really have to if you're not posted and
so it puts me in a bad spot as a
sportsman because I work very hard not
to tell the not to provide landowners
and I'm going to confess to something a
simple answer by saying all you got to
do is post your land and I can end this
call in just a few minutes get some
signs and I can read to you how it
should be posted post your land it can't
be on it that's not what we should be
doing in fish and game I think we should
be trying to mitigate as much as we can
between the landowner and the hunters
and this was an effort to do that so the
cameras have become more popular
representative Smith asked us earlier
and I think for two reasons one is the
technology has really improved it's
they're highly successful in harvesting
game and the price I mean you can buy a
camera today for 39 so the price did it
and I think the world we live in quite
frankly dictated it I think Hunters see
it as a tool when they're working busy
schedules like we all are and they put
the cameras out to do some of that
hunting so I crafted this originally and
I worked with the two groups that I've
already three groups that have already
mentioned that kind of word Smith that
make sure we're all on the same page and
we worked very hard at it number of
things happened here in the world of
compromise and I'm not best known for
compromise I'll be the first to admit so
I want the record to reflect I'm here
today prepared to do that because that's
how important it is to the landowners
behind me and and passing this is more
important probably than some of the
things I personally want we put in I put
in the paragraph about cellular cameras
because that concerns me because it
flies directly in the face of fair Chase
I think as an agency we should promote
Fair Chase cellular cameras the ones
that provide instant pictures to folks
my experience has been and we do make
several cases on this now but my
experience has been people are sitting
in their homes they're setting these up
on bait sites behind their homes not
everybody but there are a number of
people doing that and they're allowing
the camera to do the hunt and to me
that's not right and so my effort when
we did this bill was to prevent that
from happening I'm not going to die on
my sword for that it's more important I
think the rest of this and and so the
other thing that came out in this from
legislative Services was the written
permission part and I think that I don't
know why that was put in there I never
intended anyone to get written
permission and I didn't intend that for
two reasons one I don't think landowners
are comfortable doing it they feel like
they're Believe It or Not landowners
feel like if they sign their name that
they're now responsible so they may say
no just for that reason two I get
permits all the time trapping permits
tree stand permits uh uh baiting permits
I don't need another permit all I want
is Hunters to be able to get permission
to be on there and they can do that
verbally and so how would that work you
would ask if a name is on a camera or a
contact information I'll talk about that
in a minute is on a camera and I can
call Jim splain I'll pick on on
representative spleen I can call Jim and
say hey Jim you're on representative
Brown's land did you have permission to
put that camera out there yes I did I
can check on that I can call Mr Brown if
I if I want to and I can say did you
give Jim splain permission I don't need
a written permission slip so if that's a
hang up for folks
um now I need to be careful because I
don't know how many Commissioners are
watching me testify my Commissioners but
I am supposed to get permission for my
commission if I make changes I certainly
would bring that and encourage my
commission to consider amending that
piece of it we didn't write that
originally I said permission I never
said written and I think OLS used
written because we use written and
everything else so I think that's why
that happened so and name and contact
information is very important to be able
to identify a camera that's not legal it
also has a history of making people
responsible I understand the concerns of
you know putting my name and my contact
I originally wrote name and address I
rethought that and said name and contact
information I am not in favor of just a
cell phone I need a name or a way to get
a name
um because someone could just not answer
the cell phone you could never get
anyone to pick the phone up so then
again I've got and here's the other
thing that I didn't tell you we collect
these I could probably open my own store
I have hundreds of cameras that that
people have never claimed because they
are they're afraid they're in trouble
and I have no way to get them I don't
want their cameras I want to get it back
to them it's their equipment but I have
no way of knowing whose it is so believe
it or not it would help us do that
um I and and I will speak to this I know
landowners I get it I'm I don't own
anywhere near the some of the wonderful
Acres these guys behind me own but I but
what I do own is very important to me
and I paid a lot of money for it um and
I and it is open to hunting and and
fishing so or access to fishing so uh I
would be very upset if I saw a camera on
my land and no one had the courtesy to
just say hey I'm gonna put I don't even
care where you put it I just want to
know who it is so that I know someone
out there is a sportsman it's not
someone spying on me it's just a simple
respect and courtesy
um
and I forget why I was going this way
but um so putting oh I and I understand
the desire when I find that as a
landowner to go out and remove that
that's my land and and I want to remove
that let me tell you how that has
created a problem I have a young lady
called me she found a camera pointing
towards her residence uh that she she
failed as some folks do she failed to
tell me the whole story but the whole
story was she used to live there she was
she was thrown out of it by the town she
was going back to that home uh for
whatever reason and so the police
department put up a camera to watch the
house she saw the camera on her house on
her own land she destroyed the camera to
get it down and then the police
department came after her to pay for the
damages to the camera and and she her
call to me was can they do that
absolutely they can do that that's their
private property so if you go out and
you cut a cable on a camera or you you
do damage to a camera or if you give it
back to the Hunter and you've got a
hunter who's miserable and he says oh my
camera doesn't work anymore you're going
to be liable for the damn
to me it's better to have us do that law
enforcement do that that's why law
enforcement doesn't allow people to take
abandoned cars doesn't allow them to do
any of that stuff because you're putting
a landowner in in the uh those
crosshairs for time for liability so
it's better to
um call law enforcement to do that so
uh 33 years I've been doing this I've
never had a complaint from a landowner
who says I'm getting too many calls
asking for permission I've never had
that happen
maybe that will happen in this but I but
I believe if you're making them ask
permission and they're posting their
names on it you're not going to get that
many people I'll tell you what you do
get and it's appalling I don't know if
any of you go to the deer hunting page
on the Facebook I'm not a social media
guy but these young guys that I hire
have driven me to do some of this much
to my dismay and I follow that page on
occasion you'd be amazed what you see so
on more than one occasion I've seen
folks with cameras that have been
hunting a piece of land like I do year
after year after year and it slowly
becomes my land because I'm shooting
deer on it and I've never seen the
landowner and so I get that thought
process in my head that that's my spot
and then they'll post a picture of
someone walking in front of their camera
and they'll say do you know who this guy
is he's on my he's in my spot on two
occasions it's been the landowner
now do I have to explain to you how
angry they are when that happens and
they see that and and people are
swearing at them and they're the
landowner he has more right to be there
than anyone else so it's just an example
of what I what we're trying to mitigate
here and so this bill would go a long
ways to do that
uh representative spleen brought a good
point about you know do we need a
criminal law no this law applies to
everybody no matter what so the good
news in New Hampshire is criminal law
and Fish and Game law apply to everybody
equally so a trooper can enforce a fish
and game law I can enforce a criminal
law so this law defines a camera not
just as a tool for hunting but as a tool
for observation so you wouldn't need any
additional law this one would cover it
all and as regards to the fine we
originally put in a hundred dollar fine
I thought that was sufficient the Senate
boosted that up to a thousand they felt
after the testimony that the hundred
dollars wasn't enough and they boosted
it to a thousand one other point I want
to make about finds this young man
talking behind me the hunter it
concerned me because he mentions that he
would have a lot of cameras out in this
bill would come into effect we obviously
wouldn't in the first year probably make
any cases on this we would we would like
we do with any law change significant
change we would issue warnings to folks
hey the law change you got to get your
camera out of there you got to put your
name on it you got to do all these
things we would do that before we'd ever
write a ticket the first 30 days so
um
a couple things I want to just remind
you of when you're thinking about voting
for this there are a number of states
out west there's a move in the west to
Outlaw cameras completely this has
become such a problem in some places and
I'll tell you the Outfitters out there
are using them the guide Outfitters that
have multiple operations going they're
putting cameras out they're
photographing trophy animals and they're
selling the location to their to their
Sports to their Hunters
not necessarily I guess a horrible thing
I don't like it but I don't but
landowners are fed up with that because
people are making money on their land
and so the legislation I'm guessing
that's why the legislature has moved
Outlaw cameras so I don't want that to
happen in New Hampshire I want to get
control of this before it gets worse and
I and I would encourage you to remember
that these complaints start in October
and go right through into December
um it is a number one complaint that we
get and I think it could be fixed with
something like this I don't know oh one
other thing was the town that we we
Exempted
all public lands so we Exempted state
land I said State managed land that was
to cover White Mountain National Forest
properties
uh Town lands Municipal lands are not
private lands they have public lands so
this law would not apply on Town only
land state land uh Wildlife Management
units or federal land it would only
apply to privately owned properties so
you wouldn't need to address that that's
in there now
okay
um
and one other uh one other
question I want to I guess I won't I
guess I'm good unless you have questions
of me I tried to sum this up as quickly
as I could thank you Colonel are there
any questions representative Smith
thank you Mr chairman thank you Colonel
for taking my questions yes sir
um first question I have and I asked
early on to I think someone else
testifying
how would Fish and Game ensure that the
property owner has posted signage to
ensure it's adequate in other words I
can have eight miles of boundary along
with one sign yeah you could so you know
to be honest with you the requirement
for posting comes in if you are if you
want to post your property and you want
to make sure that the first person who
trespass on your land we can prosecute
there is a manner of posting for that
and if you have followed that I can take
the first person you call me on so when
Jim spleen crosses onto your property
you could call me this afternoon and Jim
splain would get a ticket if you didn't
have that sign in the right location or
you didn't have enough signs up I would
then go to Jim splain and tell him
this land is posted even though that
sign wasn't up where you went in this
land is posted you no longer can come
back and then I can summons him the
second time in in your case where we're
not all they're doing is offering up
that the land is open so if someone were
to make a case if we went in and we
found a camera uh and the guy said hey I
saw a sign that said it was okay to put
these cameras out there and we saw that
sign no one's going to make a case on
that as long as I don't see that same
requirement being in place
um that was something a landowners asked
for because they didn't want to
continually get the calls they felt that
they would get a number of calls I I
would predict you're not going to get a
number of calls that's my prediction but
but to answer your question it wouldn't
be required
thank you any further questions
representative Khan
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
Connor Jordan for taking my question yes
sir
um
private property inside private property
is not acceptable you know that is we
all understand that knowing all those
things you know the sign we just saw
if the property owner doesn't have this
sign in their property yeah there there
could be a you know issue that Hunter
didn't know about this law
and how you resolve that issue so we res
we resolved that all the time with folks
that they we make it their
responsibility to know the laws uh we
would do Public Notices If This Were to
change because this is a significant
change when when fishing games changes
laws like this we release that publicly
we also have a period of time within as
I said within that first year where we
cut people slack to kind of get them
like we did with a lead when lead uh
fishing tackle came in I think it was
two years before we ever issued a
summons for it we want to make sure
everybody was aware and up to speed with
it so we we take that into account and
then we publicize the change
the other thing I want to speak to Mr
chairman was a suggestion you had made
me privately I hope it's all right to
bring it up contact information being a
cell number and maybe a hunting license
number that's a great idea but when I
was in the back of the room the only
problem I think that that might create
if we have someone out there watching
Wildlife it's not required to have a
hunting license so I don't know how they
would do it unless we allow for them to
put their name I'm okay with that but
but I understand the concerns that that
Diane has brought up with putting your
name posting your name and having access
to that the only thing I'd remind you we
do require that on a number of things
now we've not had any issues Trappers
have to have their name and address we
should probably go back and change that
in today's world uh bow Hunters have to
have it on and bait stands have to be
posted with their name so we're doing
that a lot now and we're not having
issues but I'm hoping as long as I get
as we can figure out who the owner is
I'm good with whatever we come up with
thank you as long as my commission is
next year let's try to make all the
names uniform in the way we tell them
how to put it so that all of the things
we have to label right have it all the
same we should we should go back and
change something we can do that as a
housekeeping representative goalie
thank you Mr chair thank you Colonel
thank you
would it be
okay if we just put the language to say
your name or license number
yes those who don't hunt I didn't have a
name and if you hunt you can just put
your license I think that would be okay
yes I think my commission could support
that okay any further questions
representative Smith and then
representative Brown thank you Mr
chairman and thank you Colonel again yes
sir I have a question regarding I'm
going to read what this says it's in
paragraph four
um a property owner shall contact a
local or state law enforcement officer
or conservation officer to remove and
seize a game camera which was placed in
violation of this section
my question is
twofold one what would be the violation
if they didn't do that and two where in
state law does it say they can't remove
property that's been placed on their own
personal property without getting
permission from phishing it doesn't
there's no law against that so they
wouldn't be violating any law the only
thing they'd be opening themselves up to
is the Civil liability if they do damage
to it or don't return it they'd have to
return it immediately because it believe
it or not as crazy as it is that's
personal property that could be charged
with theft so it just my suggestion of
not allowing them to do that just
exempts them from all of that but let me
be clear there's no law that that
prevents it now a land we have
landowners do that there's no law they
haven't violated the law they've exposed
themselves to liability if there's an
issue thank you follow up real quick
follow-up
so if I found a backpack in my just like
a game camera I have every right to take
that absolutely not being criminally
charged you absolutely do you'd be if
you did damage to it or didn't return it
you could face criminal charges or civil
yes
thank you and representative Brown
uh thank you Mr chairman thank you
Colonel yes sir take my question
um we talked a lot about what's
enforceable or not in the lobster Bill
sure so what
um what's your thought about the wording
uh on line 12 about the 24 hours so it
says within 24 hours of remotely viewing
any image of that animal from a game
camera that area that's probably
something you can't really enforce on so
I'll tell you we when we wrote that into
rule our goal was to show the world
frankly that we were trying to a peace
Fair Chase we didn't ever expect to make
a case for that very reason quite
frankly we make a lot of cases on it and
I don't understand why we're doing it
we're asking people based on the facts
and circumstances of when we find these
things for instance a bait site with a
cellular camera on it and and people are
telling us when those pictures are taken
so we're making a lot of cases on it so
I just thought it was better as an
agency to promote Fair Chase principles
and that's why we did it originally that
and that I put that in here it's in Rule
now so we're enforcing it like that now
in our administrative rules I felt if
we're going to create a rule for cameras
we should be up front and put that up
front
thank you any further questions
I do have one more thank you you may
follow up follow up
um do you have a feeling about the the
amount of the fine you would initially
went with a hundred and then you
acquiesce to the Thousand from Senate it
seems a little high to me do you have a
number that you prefer so I I wrote in a
hundred
because I I was envisioning multiple
cameras so a thousand concerns my
experience has been with my with all
officers if the fine is really high they
don't issue it they issue warnings and
so you don't get good enforcement to me
we should I to me I think we should come
back a little bit the other way half
halfway and and mirror it to other
equipment violations thank you yes sir
thank you and representative page
that was my question oh okay uh
representative
oulette
thank you Mr chairman uh Colonel yes as
I read the fine session it says up to a
thousand dollars that's correct
mandatory correct that's that's a good
point that's exactly right so and I you
know now that you said that I think
that's because that's the way it's
written in criminal code for violations
is up to a thousand dollars but that's
exactly what I said to the vice chair
here is is the the up to a thousand
dollars was not off of your fine
schedule no they used the criminal code
that's correct which
we're not used to seeing because we
usually see your fines right we have set
Vines normally but I I would be open to
a lesser fine but you're right that's a
very good point
any further questions representative
pair this is sort of a follow-up to that
so with up to a thousand dollars you
already have the um luxury of charging
less we could defense could be a hundred
dollars second offense blah blah blah as
long as somebody's a repeat offender or
has 27 cameras out there a thousand
dollars sounds good as long as the judge
approved it that's correct it'll be
subject to judicial approval but yes you
could that's what it's that's why it's
worded that way
thank you any further questions
and I'm going to leave you with one yes
which is uh do you mind if this takes
effect on a January 1st rather than
within 60 days I don't think that's an
issue I I don't I don't believe it's an
issue I found that trying to get things
through rules tends to be better if it's
a January 1st date rather than a 60 days
that's always we don't ever push that
that's always left up to the legislature
so yes
thank you seeing no further questions
I'm going to close the testimony on SB
14 and thank God for his time
committee we've gone over your lunch
time a little bit what we're going to do
is come back at 1 30 for the one o'clock
Bill and I'm gonna have the assistant
post a notice on the door that the bill
will start at 1 30. we are allowed to
start later than the time we're just not
allowed to start before the time that's
posted so uh everybody can still have an
hour for lunch get yourself fed
that's right
being 130
I already got a bunch of those uh
different build I guess oh same person
okay I believe
I'm going to open the hearing on SB 15
and I'm going to recognize Senator
Howard Pearl the prime sponsor
good afternoon members of the fish and
game committee it's a pleasure to be
back on the house side again and uh I
want to introduce Senate Bill 15 FM for
the record my name is Senator Howard
Pearl representing District 17 and I
live in Loudon
I'm introducing SB 15fn at the request
of the Fish and Game Commission to add
language regulating tree stands
hopefully it will provide Clarity that
permanent tree stands require written
permission from the landowner the
current language does not differentiate
between permanent or temporary tree
stands
also it will provide time frames for
erecting portable tree stands if a
property owner permits hunting on their
land temporary tree stands are allowed
without the need for written permission
between August 1st and December 31st
additionally it will add a new
requirement for the labeling of tree
stands all tree stands will be required
to the name and contact information of
the tree stand owner that's in the event
that an issue arises and that needs to
be addressed
the tree stand language was first
brought forward in the Senate amendment
to House Bill 490 last session but that
bill ultimately died during the
committee of conference process however
landowners continue to call Fish and
Game to express their frustration that
these changes are not in current law
the intent of Senate Bill 15 FN is to
address those complaints so landowners
will keep their lands open for hunting
and recreational purposes
this bill is supported by both the New
Hampshire Timberland Owners Association
and the New Hampshire Farm Bureau we do
have Colonel Jordan here from Fish and
Game and he'll certainly answer any of
the technical questions you have but I'm
willing to answer anything you have from
me
thank you for your testimony and for
introducing the bill and welcome back
good to be here any questions
Senator representative Smith thank you
Mr chairman and thank you senator
reading through the bill I just have a
question maybe you can clarify it it
says no person shall construct a
permanent tree stand or observation
blind without written permission from
the property owner or designee
permanent could be subjective how would
you clarify permanent because there's uh
these blinds that are considered hard
signal excuse me hard sided panel blind
ground blinds where you can pop them
together take them apart is that
permanent not permanent it seems like it
could be a gray area there when it comes
to determining what is permanent well
thanks for the question and this bill is
really referring to tree stands and not
not anything on ground Mount and I I
think you'll I'll let the colonel speak
to this but I think you're going to find
that the the definition that is referred
to by permanent means anything that's
affixed to the tree using some type of a
permanent lag nail not not something
that's strapped on it you know could be
a with a ratchet strap or something like
that I think they're looking at
something that's going to permeate the
tree bark and and you know indicate more
of a permanent structure than something
that's temporary but I'll let I'll let
the colonel speak to that a little
further but thanks for the question
any other questions
seeing none thank you Senator well you
guys gonna let me off easy
it seems so all right well thank you
appreciate it
the chair will now call Kyle Baker
supports the bill two minutes
good afternoon like probably faster than
two minutes
um Kyle Baker with Wildlife Federation
I'm just here to support the bill
um to us it's a pretty basic
um if you're going to leave a piece of
gear on somebody else's property you
should put your name and contact
information on it
um it makes sense it's better for the
Sportsman it helps prevent gear getting
stolen if it does get stolen getting
back to the proper the proper owner as
well as gives the opportunity for a
landowner to reach out if they have
concerns about where the stand is placed
so
um that's it just wanted to Echo our
support uh but happy to take any
questions
that was quick any questions
representative Brown thank you Mr chair
do you have a feeling on time frame of
this uh we're open to time frame uh you
know the main thing for us was that
folks should be checking their stands at
least once a year
um the the straps can get dry rotted if
they're out in the sun the straps can
get frozen or this just deteriorate over
time
um think anything you know there are
just you know metal equipment they can
start to degrade over time so not only
checking it uh once uh once a year is
important but also that interaction
between the Hunter and the landowner is
important so if your landowner says hey
you can keep it up in perpetuity we
still think you should be out there at
least once a year checking your
equipment but if you want to leave it
that's between you and the landowner but
as far as what time of year you do that
um you know we've heard you know we
talked to the chairman you know in the
in the dead of winter might not
necessarily be the safest time to do it
so
um we're happy to
whatever we think whatever everybody can
agree on is fine with us
any other questions
seeing none thank you so much for your
testimony
the chair calls Stephen wood
supports the bill three minutes
oh thank you again
um for listening to my nonsense
um I am still Stephen wood I still own a
bunch of land in Lebanon and Plainfield
unless Something's Happened in my
absence today I still manage poverty
land orchards in front of Hill ciders
um and I'm here in in vigorous support
of what I consider to be a very
marginally flawed bill
um and I won't go through all the things
I said before everything I said before
about respect and civility
we all stand for this bill as well
um
yet and I said this at the house side as
well I think I think not just permanent
but all Stan should should require
permission now that's where that sign
that we gave I gave you last time uh
that's probably in the recycling now
um
it comes in because we're requiring
permission anyway
so the people come and ask permission
for this stuff again as the our our
usual experience is that people by
Nature ask permission
um and I will say that for what it's
worth I haven't spoken to a single
landowner who wasn't amazed that these
bills were necessary that is to say that
people were now Allowed by right to do
these things
um and and so I mean I I just the same
thing I think people should have the
facility facility civility to ask
permission to do these things which is
almost always given
um and uh I didn't there's one other
thing I didn't say that last time which
is that when when people come to get
written permission from us
they now get a couple of pages they get
they get
um they get a black and white
um aerial photo with the property lights
and all our lands so they don't wander
off to a a neighbor's land inadvertently
um they if we have any particular
requests or requirements for a
particular piece of land that's for that
year that's detailed on that again
they're very glad to have this
interchange and I think this is part of
the deal is trying to encourage that
sort of interchange between the users of
private property and the private
property owners themselves so I support
this I hope and I hope you will I
support this bill with that one regret
which is that I think it should be
required
for all of this
thank you that's
thank you are there any questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you for your time
uh Chris Fife
has written testimony
is that what we passed out before all
right thank you sb14 thank you yes Chris
Fife with warehouser also the president
of New Hampshire Timberland Owners
Association and testifying on behalf of
Weyerhaeuser I will skip most of the
intro if it's in the written testimony
and uh all you've all heard it already I
I would just say specific to tree stands
and sb15 that the requirements for
labeling a tree stand with the name and
contact information and a requirement
for removal by January 1st our Common
Sense steps I think respect the
landowners rights
and still maintain that tradition of
hunting in the state
I we see sb15 as an opportunity to
improve communication between our
Foresters and the owners of tree stands
or observation blinds through that
requirement for labeling with the name
and contact information of the owner of
the tree stand or observation blind in a
clearly visible manner this is a
requirement in other states where we
have land Timberland that we manage it's
not been an issue no one seems to have a
problem with it and it certainly
facilitates us being able to contact a
hunter if we have an operation a harvest
operation in the area often hunters will
put these stands out ahead of the season
they don't know our plans
obviously
and we will come across them during the
course of an operation Harvest operation
and if we have no way to contact the
owner or put in a position of either
having to go around that tree which our
business is not in growing trees to put
stands on although we support that in
the interim while those trees are
growing
or we have to take the stand down
sometimes they just aren't seen and
stands get destroyed and this isn't an
uncommon thing this is something that
happens unfortunately and it's not
something that our we as a company our
Foresters or certainly a logger want to
have happen is to destroy somebody's
property I don't believe hunting stands
are 39 a piece yet so Dave we recognize
the value there
so this really for us is a common sense
way to increase that communication and
to give us an opportunity to know who to
contact if we have an issue as far as
removal by January 1st this gives us an
indication as a landowner that that is
not a permanent fixture
there certainly stands that I've come
across in our Timberlands where it's
obvious by the state of the stand that
it's been out there for years and just
left and I don't think that's respectful
by the hunter I don't think it's
something that a landowner should have
to expect I think that at that point it
becomes trash
there certainly are cases that I just
want to mention just like with game
cameras if circumstances Beyond a
hunter's control a big snowstorm in
November that dumps two feet of snow and
they can no longer get to the stand
something like that happens they contact
us
that's all we're going to want we're
finding we're going to say okay you know
make sure you get out there and retrieve
that when you can but we see that just
as much as a sign of respect contacting
us recognizing we don't want our roads
and our infrastructure negatively
impacted by someone trying to remove a
tree stand so I know you can't really
write that into legislation very easily
but I want you to understand that that's
our uh that that's our desire that's how
we we interact with hunters and again
just reiterate that we see Hunters as
allies who's you know these users are
their eyes and ears in the woods for us
they're uh they are us really in most
cases and so uh we certainly are trying
to work together
and with that I will just ask
respectfully to you uh support this past
this bill as presented and be willing to
answer any questions
thank you sir uh representative goalie
thank you Mr chair
so
if a stand is put on a piece of property
I know there's especially in the North
Country some large
tracks of land that are managed for
Timber
and that stands in the middle of a piece
of property that you're getting ready to
harvest
now it
ends up taking time away from you going
forward with your project
costing you probably some money going
out there taking it down and now having
to how is this somewhere until you get a
hold of fishing game or
find the right owner is it not costing
you time and money if you don't know
that it's out there when you come upon
one as you get ready to harvest of
course
doubt that's accurate yes you know any
of those extras
do just take time away from the real job
of managing Timber
thank you any further questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today thank you
the uh chair calls Jason stock
supports the bill New Hampshire
Timberland Association
good afternoon again for the record
Jason stock executive director of the
New Hampshire Timberland Owners
Association and
um
come here today to speak in support of
how of Senate Bill 15. similar to the
similar to the camera Bill we we and as
you heard in the prior testimony we
believe this bill really represents what
we think is just kind of common courtesy
um if you're going to leave a tree stand
up for any extended period of time and I
I would qualify that as a year
at that point you should you should ask
that landowner or is it all right if I
leave it up beyond that I think there
are folks that that do that already but
this codifies in law that that is in
fact the case
um the other piece of this is labeling
um and labeling it I you'll go to any
logging logging garage or forester's
office in in November and in the corner
it looks like a hunter's pick and save
where there's a pile of stands game
cameras
um as we mentioned before I need that
address okay that's right Fort Mountain
companies
so but you know they'll have the a pile
of tree stands a pile of game cameras
there and they'll say I don't want those
but I don't know who to contact I don't
have a name I don't have a phone number
so again we think this is this works
this works both ways I can now and and
what will typically happen is they'll
leave her business card on the on the
tree stand or the game camera and
there's no response so you're getting
ready to do your Timber sale and all of
a sudden
you know we gotta we've gotta we can't
cut this tree down and and with a stand
on it so it does re does require or as
representative goalie it does take time
and energy and it's just kind of A
disruption to the flow of things
um
and so it the other point is you know we
we looked at the to answer the question
about permanent versus temporary we we
looked at that in drafting this when we
were with working with the Wildlife
Federation and Farm Bureau and Fish and
Game and you know we we looked at that
and said look there are climbing stands
now that I can walk into a woodlot climb
up hunt and at the end of the day climb
back down and go about my business and
we said well that's you know that's not
really a permanent stand and it's
it's barely a temporary stand in that
you're using it it's essentially a
little platform that you stand on for
the purpose of the day so what we did
was we tried to craft a bill that that
incorporated some common sense that says
basically look if you're going to leave
it there Beyond January one it starts
looking it starts looking like a
permanent structure you should get
permission
and as as Mr Fife testified earlier it
does it it does re you know it induces a
dialogue with that landowner that land
manager so for all those reasons we we
come here today in full support of
Senate Bill 15 and I'd be happy to try
to answer any questions
are there any questions
representative pair
thank you excuse me thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question
um on paragraph five in the uh bill that
we have starting on line 14. uh it talks
about portable stands and it says that
um they can be erected without
permission and all uh tree stands have
to be removed by January 1st now was
your definition of a portable or
temporary stand what you just spoke of
um the one that you come come in it's to
get you a ladder to get up in the tree
it goes up for the day and it comes down
when you leave or which
sounds like to me a temporary stand this
sounds like a semi-permanent stand and I
was wondering if something was Lost in
Translation no they're they're both in
in what I in what I would say is is that
you have a climber that's that's a
temporary stand I hunt with a a
temporary stand on on my property that I
will put up I'll leave it there for
hunting season but at the end of the you
know at the end of hunting season I take
it down it doesn't it doesn't clip into
the tree or you know damage the tree or
harm the tree and so that's really in in
Colonel Jordan can speak to this more
but really when we look at the
definition between permanent and
temporary it really gets to what Senator
Pearl said is are you kind of driving
pins or nails or screws into it is it
being affixed to that tree a climber is
it a temporary stand but so is a
non-climber that just kind of hangs on
it in my case it has like a nylon strap
ladder stands what's that ladder stance
ladder stands same way it's you have a
ladder and then a platform and that
ladder actually has a has like a nylon
strap that you ratchet on and it just
kind of hugs the tree doesn't cut it
doesn't drive into it but that's that's
another form is a ladder stand mine's
called a loggy bayou it's a little
little stand that has a little rope
nylon rope that just ties onto the back
of the stand and
that's it but I leave it up for multiple
months during deer season
follow up follow up I'm not sure if
there's a question for you and maybe
it's covered in the bill that I and I
didn't catch it but even one of these if
it's going to be up for longer than
today's Hunting Expedition then it
should be should be labeled the same as
the other ones yeah they all should be
labeled in in our opinion that's what we
read this bill as is you would require a
label for all of them
thank you thank you
any further questions
seeing none thank you testimony today uh
we're gonna call Diane Richardson
hi I'm Diane Richardson still from the
Lake Sunapee area and
um I actually
support this bill for the most part
um my only caveat is the labeling with
the name on it because that's putting a
Target on people's backs
phone number fine hunting license fine
putting your name on it every year I see
many many posts where people have been
had their tree stands targeted by
anti-hunters or jealous hunters or
people that want that spot or something
and they'll have their stands
uh vandalized or stolen or something and
I think putting a name on it is just
asking for more trouble than we already
have
and that's it
thank you any questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today
chair calls uh Ginny Christensen
I'm Jenny christenton and my husband and
I
um my husband Tom and I own a 700 acre
Tree Farm in both lineborough and
Greenfield can you both can you all hear
me okay thank you our land has been open
to hunting since 1972.
we know a lot of the hunters that have
come by over the years but we don't know
all of them we manage our tree farm for
Timber wildlife and Recreation in fact
our land was all Woods in the beginning
and we've created Wildlife openings
which actually has benefited the hunters
because we have more wildlife
um we don't know all of the hunters
we ask is this courtesy for the ones
that we know could you tell us where the
tree stands are and there's a couple
reasons for this
this is our backyard we have a lot of
hunt of hikers that come through we'd
like the hunters to know exactly where
are the hikers so we can see where
they're going to put the stand is it
going to be safe for the hikers and also
in case there are more than one Hunter
will they put their deer stands far
enough apart so it it's um better for
them
better for them
you were mentioning how deer stands are
installed we've come across old deer
stands that have been nailed into the
trees and that's basically rule in that
whole section of the tree some of the
deer stands are put in with straps
if the deer stand is abandoned those
straps constrict the tray the tree goes
around them and again we've lose the
value of that wood
um
one reason is because of the hikers but
also if we have a harvest cut we'd like
to be able to know who has the stand so
we can take it down because some of them
will just leave them there a couple
years ago we had a tree stand in a
harvest area Tom went out and cut the
thing off
and fell while he was doing it he got up
shaken and bruised but it could have
been worse
it would have been so much easier if
there was a name on the stand he could
have called him up and said please will
you come and remove the stand
um
we are like I said open to hunting we
don't want to have to if there are
problems take our land out of hunting
because we do understand that the
hunters are man helping to manage the
wildlife that's out there
I do have some written testimony and
just a quick thing we were not able to
get to the um hearing for this morning
for game cameras
our tree farm is our backyard I really
don't want to have deer cameras out
there okay that can be taking pictures
of me at any time or being broadcast
somewhere okay I'm sure none of you
people would like a camera in your
backyard taking pictures of you
I would like to thank you for allowing
me to testify here again I'm supporting
SB 14 and SB 15. as written I do have
three copies of written testimony but I
only have three I'm sorry
okay do you have any questions
you can pass your copies up to
representative Ming who will make sure
the clerk gets them to make copies for
everybody
and are there any questions
thank you seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony
the chair calls Robert Johnson II
foreign
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee for the record again Rob
Johnson representing the New Hampshire
fambio as the federation's policy
director and speaking in support of
Senate bill 15. again we did work with
as you've heard with the Timberland
owners Wildlife Federation and fishing
game on this this bill as well and I
think most of what is what I had
anticipated saying has been said I'll
just touch on two items that I know
there have been some questions on and
and I guess the first is the the
labeling piece it's uh something that a
strong strong piece of the bill that
that we support we find that many of our
members already think that it's a
requirement is again for the reasons
that have been mentioned just the
ability to to contact somebody to know
whose it is or to return it and as far
as the information the the specific
requirement on the labeling we would
want a just a phone number would be
concerning to us because we you know if
we can somebody go to number rocking
ring and ring and ring you don't get it
I would prefer to have it if it's not
the name the the hunting license ID so
then we can fishing game could be
contacted and then we can get a name
um that would be good and then the
second piece I'll touch on is uh where
there have been questions is the the the
date the stand
um to come down
um the date itself is not important to
us the important piece that there is a
date when there's a check-in when the
the stand is removed by so that that if
uh um you know if they've checked in and
they've already get in Orlando it gives
permission it's up to your own that's
fine but we want that check in so that
we can be sure that the stands are are
removed um you know on a what again
whatever that date may be whether it's
March 15th April 1st January 1st but
again the date is important so that
there's that uh that dialogue in it it
doesn't become a permanent fixture on
the property and I'll leave my testimony
at that thank you again for your time
thank you any questions
representative Brown
um thank you Mr Sharon and thank you for
taking my question sorry to be confused
uh you said you don't uh you you don't
have a specific uh requirement for a
date but you you said check in so let me
know what you mean by that yeah well the
the Bill calls for the the stands be
removed by January 1. if if that date
were to change I know there's been some
voice I'm concern about January 1 being
winter if it were a different time of
the year uh in the in the spring or the
fall whenever we just think having a
date is important when there is that
that that check-in that when that
happens that's what I'm saying
thank you any further questions
uh representative goalie
I just want to follow up on that
question so
what you're saying is with the check-in
date you don't want them permanent
without you knowing about them correct
thank you
any further questions seeing none thank
you and Dan dockham will be called next
foreign
Mr chairman members of the commission uh
thank you for the opportunity to give my
comments I have been a little confused
and my biggest concern is that with tree
stands I don't mind them but I do want
people to ask permission because I want
to specify that they can only use
portable tree stands and the reason for
that is a number of years ago I had a
beautiful red oak on my property I've
got a lot of red oak
and this tree was probably as big as a
55 gallon drum in diameter
and it wasn't a limb for 25 feet or more
which means it would grade the highest
like veneer that type of thing
and someone came in and they had these
screw steps
they're a lag thread it's about three
inches long that they screw into the
tree and then there's a little saddle
like put to feed into climb them
so you know they ruined a lot of money
there ask any of the folks in the
chemistry
and then another similar deal where I
was helping a friend and
we cut a bunch of Pine and brought it to
was a small Mill wasn't one of the big
commercial ones and I know nowadays they
have magnets or whatever to scan the log
before they saw it but some of the
smaller Mills I don't think are equipped
with that and so when they start sawing
the board a lot of these spikes they
used to scrap lumbar two by fours
whatever Spike them to the tree to get
up where they want to sit and they just
left them like that the wood
deteriorates over a period of time the
back Grows Right Out Over the Spike
heads so you can't detect them and when
you take those to The Sawmill and they
start souring it and it wrecks the teeth
you have to pay for that
so I guess I just wanted to make sure
that you know that's in the new proposal
right or was it something that's already
been in the past so I can let you know
that under current law and in fact
you'll see it in item one no person
shall erect build or use a tree stand or
observation blind on land of another
person that damages or destroys a tree
by inserting into the tree any metallic
ceramic or other object used as part of
a land or observation ladder or
observation deck without Express written
permission from the property owner or
designee is already in the lawn it's
been in the law for at least 50 years
so so that the situation you describe is
already illegal and this bill is just
adding in some new sections to deal with
the portable type that don't puncture
the tree
okay
so I still I guess I'm still in favor of
it because I like the idea asking
because not everybody knows the law or
bothers to even look them up
and so I can say yes you can put a tree
stand up but it's going to be portable
and that would be my biggest thing for
supporting it thank you any questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
and I'll call the last person Kevin
Jordan
thank you for the opportunity
sitting away in the back like you don't
have to talk anymore today
thank you again for having me
um
just quickly it was it was we worked on
this the same time we did the camera
bill because again it was a major
complaint of a lot of the landowners
that we were getting calls on and they
were this one's a little different
because there is a belief among amongst
the sportsmen and women they have to put
their name on their tree stands
um I know I'm not sure where that comes
from but there's a lot of people that
think they have to we we would ask the
only change in this you'd be correct is
uh we are asking for names and contact
information to be put on we talked this
morning at the camera Bill about maybe
using a hunting license I don't I don't
object to that I did have a landowner
come up to me made a very good point he
said you know sometimes we want to
handle that on our own
without getting law enforcement involved
because they feel like you know and I
get that I you don't want to anger the
hunter thinking Nicole game a game
warden so they said the name would be
helpful to them because then they'd pick
the phone up and call Kevin Jordan and
say you got to move your stand I don't
object to that I don't fear the name
like some do because I again we have
names on a lot of things and I've not
had a lot of issues with that so
um we all know if you don't know I'm
going to tell you people leave their
stands out to mark their territory so
they have a good spot like I do I kill a
buck I harvest a buck almost every year
from the same piece of property of a
very gracious landowner and again I want
to thank the landowners here for
allowing guys like me to hunt uh he
knows I'm there and and I worry every
year right after I get my dear I go
right back in and get my stand I have a
climber much like Jason described to you
I use the same type of climber mine's a
little fancier because I like to fall
into a very deep sleep when I'm sitting
in it and it keeps me alive because as I
tip over it I hit the rail and it
straightens me back up I do manage on
occasion to get a buck and I go in the
next day and remove my stand I
understand the thought process in places
down here where there's higher hunting
pressure you leave your standout it kind
of tells other Hunters that's my spot
this so I thought of that when we wrote
that and I thought we can put a
provision in here that allows that but
you just gotta have permission from the
landowner to do it so I didn't want to
eliminate that so you can go to a
landowner and all of this would go by
the wayside if he gives you permission
to leave it there permanent the
difference between a permanent and a
climber by by fishing aimlar a permanent
stand would be any stand that causes any
damage to a tree so anytime you insert
anything into a tree it whether it's a
peg a hanger to hang the stand on
anything that goes into the tree or if
you cut branches or or trees down to
make a clear shot which a lot of people
do that falls under permanent tree stand
and requires written landowner
permission for that that's been in the
law for years that's never changed the
slaw doesn't change that this law is
requiring you to put your names on them
and then remove them unless the
landowner gives you permission to leave
it so we we kind of again I tried to
balance the rights of the Hunter and the
rights of the landowner so we we left a
little caveat so if you've got a
landowner that doesn't care if you leave
your stand up all year so you can mark
your territory that's fine if you do
have a landowner it gives them the
option to move it out the last thing I
wanted to address and again it's a
courtesy and respect that's all it is
and we try to teach it I'm trying to do
it when we create laws so that hunters
get into that mindset that this is not
your god-given right someone owns this
property and they're paying for it and
they're gracious enough to let us use it
and we want to protect that and preserve
it and respect it
um
the last thing is
God this is happening to me more often
than
uh then oh the date excuse me the date
so Chairman's Blaine and I spoke briefly
uh today about the date why January 1.
we picked January 1 because it was just
the beginning of a new year number one
um he brought up a a valid point you
know I don't want people leaving them
out there till January 1 and climbing
them up when they're froze climbing up
there when they're frozen and falling
out of them that's a good point I
understand that so he suggested
um having a deadline in the spring which
I'm good with that the only concern I
would have with that and Jason and his
his group could speak better to this is
a lot of those cuts happen in the
wintertime
so a lot of the cuts on the major land
happen in the winter when the ground's
frozen so that would not allow that
would not be conducive to getting those
stands out because that's really why
we're doing this is for that so although
you could argue I guess that the name is
on it they could see the name if
everybody's applied you know following
the law and you could call him out and
and say get your tree stand off because
we're going to cut it but that would be
my little concern I do agree a cutoff
date's important it doesn't I'm not as
sold on whatever date that is but I
would ask you to consider that a lot of
these properties are cut in the winter
months when it's frozen so
uh the other concern it was raised and
this is why this came up last year as I
had a landowner who was concerned about
liability his concern was we have a
permanent stand up I don't know whose it
is and if someone climbs up in that tree
stand and and falls out of it I'm going
to be held liable for that so there's
some truth to that and some not so
accurate truth to that I was in my
office two days ago I was working
diligently like I always do I turned
around this is a true story I turned
around to face a U.S attorney assistant
standing there with paperwork in his
hand now I in I've been in this business
a long time I've been sued I believe six
times total
and luckily always followed the law you
get sued for following the law that's
the best way to get sued because you're
protected so and this is what this
lawsuit is so I was served with a
lawsuit because I followed the law I
wouldn't allow a guide to become a guide
because he was a convicted felon he
committed a homicide and was locked up
for it he wanted to be a hunting guide
it didn't make sense to me and I said no
the rules don't allow for that and he is
suing me which is that's a good place to
be where I am right now I'm good with
that so my point here is even if there's
a law like we have a good liability law
for hunting even if there's a law you
can be sued and it costs money to prove
you're right and and a good example of
that was the Hunter and the landowner in
Deerfield the farmer and I'm embarrassed
to tell you I can't remember his name
who was sued over a coyote stand if you
remember a few years ago caused a huge
uproar in liability now he won
ultimately uh fairly quickly but he paid
some attorney fees that I don't believe
he ever recouped so it cost money in
America today unfortunately sometimes to
prove you're innocent so just keep that
in mind so this landowner telling me I'm
a little concerned I know the liability
law will protect me but I'm concerned
that I could still be sued that's a real
concern so I you know that kind of
encouraged me to file this so so anyway
that's in a nutshell the landowners hit
on all the other things I think that are
important
thank you colonel uh representative
Smith
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
Colonel yes sir for listening to me blow
V8 I'm good I'm good with you bullying
me you're a very polite bullier
so I'm reading through this bill and it
appears there's no penalty in here
other than uh if damages so I'm just
going to read what it says to keep it
simple it says any person who
any person who violates any provision of
this section shall be guilty of a
violation and shall be liable for the
amount of damage caused by the ACT to be
recovered by the property owners of
standing sustaining the damage that's
implying damage to a tree correct but if
somebody doesn't label it doesn't get
written permission or keeps it out past
the deadline there is no penalty in here
right and a lot of our laws don't have a
penalty within the law because this is
amending existing law there's a penalty
in the section so in 207 RSA 207 is a
penalty uh for violations I I don't know
if it specifies a fine amount to be
honest with you it may not but it says
it's a violation law and you would lose
your hunting license for a year like in
any anything in this chapter is what it
so a lot of times when the laws are
written they put one penalty section and
a whole in a whole section of 207 or 210
has one single penalty statute so that
exists we didn't add it to this one
because we at we amended existing law so
that's why you don't see that
foreign
just carries through into the liability
uh question you were just talking I had
a call this morning on my way here same
thing a landowner was because he
supports the bill concerned about the
liability yes so I did some reading
um RSA 50814 is the landowner liability
law and RSA 21334 is a duty of care law
correct so am I correct to understand
that this homeowner will be free of
liability and he was also concerned
about having to pay for a lawyer to
defend himself but the law also states
that if it's a fraudulent or malicious
lawsuit that he can recover the cost
from the person making a lawsuit on that
you are though unfortunately that
doesn't happen very often I I wish
courts would pay better attention to
that because that's across America today
that happens these frivolous lawsuits
and people have to go in and defend
themselves and win ultimately like the
like the farmer did down in Deerfield
but it cost him a serious amount of
money to do that and and that statute
existed and there's sometimes courts
don't feel that that's appropriate they
felt that the person had the right to
bring a lawsuit or penalizing them for
doing that and so at the end of the day
the landowner still pays that money so
that's a concern the other argument that
you could make
um I had a landowner bring up a valid
point he said that's fine if they're
Hunters what if it's a kid
this is a pretty good point I told my
young officers when we train them don't
ever climb one of these because you
don't know the guys use three Nails in
that step or or One Nail you can fall
out of this thing so he his point was if
you have these permanent stands which we
don't see a lot of but there are some a
permanent stand what if a kid or someone
else who isn't hunting engaged in
Recreation he's just somebody that's
wandering on the property for whatever
reason climbs up with that same
liability protection apply and I don't
know the answer to that I think that
could be again I think it would cost the
landowner money to to prove it so that's
a concern
all set
one real quick we just were talking
about permanent stance those are already
covered under the existence it is yeah
permanent is is very well part of this
bill right now because the person we're
not changing any of that all these ones
I had a neighbor who passed away a
couple of years ago but even up till he
was 70s he was using these
permanent stands he climbed up into that
he nailed to the tree in his own
property he can do that right but
damned if I go up those
um and and that's the kind of thing that
a lot of these people are finding in the
woods is like a 30 year old abandoned
very dangerous the straps around the
ladder stand are not permanent anything
that goes around the tree if you're
cutting branches to go up you know
another example I'm I'm I hunt and I I
was using ash trees
I don't own those trees they were great
trees to hunt on it they're straight no
no you know the bark is conducive to it
and they're also very valuable but this
knucklehead didn't think of that so I
was climbing up and down out of this ash
tree in the landowner Steve Fifield was
a great guy in Canterbury
left me a note he didn't know who I was
he left me a note on my stand because my
name wasn't on it because it didn't
require that it's a temporary stand I
left the base of the tree left me a note
call me I panicked I'm you know I'm the
colonel efficient game I must have done
something wrong so I grabbed my stand
and I headed for the High Country and I
got to my Jeep and I drove right to Mr
fievel's house and I said I banged on
the door and he was shocked to see me
and another landowner testified to this
early he says you know how many years
I've left in cards on tree stands I've
never once seen anyone I said well you
did today I said I'm guilty and he said
the only problem I have with you he said
I don't want you in my ash tree those
are valuable I said what tree would you
like me to go into he said can you pick
a pine I said I can but I got to cut a
branch to get up a pine because I got
branches that's why I use ash and he
said I don't mind you cutting a branch
I'll sign for that I don't want you in
an ash it was that exchange I drove away
thinking you know therein lies the
problem we don't do that you know I
should have done that before he left me
the car now we got a good relationship
and he calls me every week wondering
where we are with the camera bill
because he hates cameras so so having
that conversation and that mutual
respect of the land I I you know what
what Dan was talking about really run
true to me I mean that you were on that
tree and that's a valuable tree I don't
look at it like I didn't look at it like
that shame on me thank you any further
questions representative goalie thank
you Mr chair
a couple questions I'll start off with
the first one
this just says that
they shall be removed by January 1st yes
doesn't stop him from removing it
December 1st or December 15th when the
weather's still good yeah before the
snow flies yeah I would remove it right
away for that reason I don't want to
call climb one when it's icy I want to
get it down and out of there that's
right you do have that option the only
argument you could make against my own
bill would be uh the chairman pointed
out if you want a coyote right if you
want a coyote hunt that happens you know
a tree stand would have to be in there
in January but again you'd go to the
landowner then and ask permission
so yes you could remove it prior to
January 1 or you could go see your
landowner which is what I hope most
would do and say is there a problem if I
leave it I don't think landowners care
about that as long as they know who it
is
uh it's not hurting their property and
and you're not in the way of one of
their Cuts I I can't imagine they tell
you to get it out of there why would
they
follow up
and
when this says
all tree stands or observation blinds
shall be labeled yes
is this included
climbing tree stands yes I would think
it would include climbing trees because
they're portable tree stands and would
it include
the observation blind I bring out in the
woods when I go turkey hunting that I
pull over my chair
has a ground blind that's I would
probably label that I don't know that
I'd ever make a case on that but I would
label that with a marker just because it
is a temporary
blind or stand
thank you you're really getting close to
the wire but I but I would do it just so
that you don't have an issue with it and
that's why I'm asking because that's an
observation blind so I'm wondering I
have one I just want for my comfort
should I label it sure yeah I think it'd
be better to do it if this passes and
one last fall follow up
when I was thinking earlier and I
suggested
using license numbers instead of
identification yep
I sat and I thought about it
and it came across as that's probably
not a good idea
and I'll tell you a reason why
anyone who does clamming and has to have
on their bucket their license number
knows it doesn't stay the same license
number unless you're a lifetime holder
year after year yeah so when you go to a
game camera you're going to run out of
space on the outside of your camera if
you've had more than five or six years
it changes that's just something to
think about I thought about it and it
hit me yeah like that so if yeah
and the landowner made a great point
when he said I really don't want to call
law enforcement every time sometimes I
want to call my Hunter and just tell him
you know kind of made sense so I don't
think it's the problem imagine me put my
name on a tree stand
you know I mean I've made one or two
enemies in this 33 years so how many
tree stands we want to buy what's that
how many tree stands you want to buy oh
yeah you got to buy or or cut the tree
half down and I get up in it you're
replacing it out yeah yeah I don't see
the issues to be honest with you I don't
see anti-hunting people I won't say it
doesn't happen but I I don't receive
those calls and I think I would if it
was a problem I think we'd hear it I
think even the anti-hunters uh wouldn't
call on you but uh
yeah you're probably right to that point
I will follow up on his comment on the
licenses
as somebody who has always labeled my
tree stand and cameras I always print a
new label each year and stick it on
anyway because after the winter it's
often faded and not any good and we
didn't while you speak of that we didn't
specify how you do that you know we
talked about that at my agency whether
we were going to engrave it or put I
wanted to leave it open for people to do
whatever they wanted but you're right if
you're putting just a label that would
be simple if you're engraving it which I
see some people would do I think some
would then you'd have to change that
license number but I'm as long as we can
find out who that owner is I don't care
what we put on it
representative Khan
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
Cardinal Jordan yes sir thank you again
uh again I want to go back to line uh 20
uh
26 the violation part yes
so is it any harm that if we put the
penalty amount or something there is a
bill to me not to have when I reading
the law and it doesn't say what is my
penalty I have to go to a few other
Pages it to me it's it gives the law a
little bit softer portion yep I I don't
think there's any issue with changing it
to read whatever you want no whatever
you one you know but I like to see
them there in the law so everybody knows
when they read it is this is the penalty
yeah thank you thank you
any further questions
representative Brown
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
Colonel yes sir I know you've already
said this twice so I'm going to start
again
uh for Diane Richardson's comments on
the concern about names we are in
putting names on anything because we are
in a new world for sure absolutely and I
don't know if that means that we all
need to just maybe watch how this works
out and uh I think she has a legitimate
point that people can take names I I
don't know if there's anti-hunters out
in the woods uh taking names or not but
right she's she says that she's seen
that so I think we should all just be
aware of that and pay attention to it
yeah it's not a question I guess but no
no but I understand your point I mean I
I think I know we have a lot of stuff
now that's labeled and we've not had any
issues the one I really suspected an
issue with was trapping
trapping we require a tag and it's it
the people that don't like harvesting
animals are probably trapping leads that
charge and I've never had a Trapper that
I'm up to my knowledge I've never had a
Trapper harass that ever so I I just
didn't think it was an issue but but I
I'm flexible either way as long as we
can determine that's the big complaint
from landowners is being able to
determine who who it is and how do I get
them I don't I don't care how we do that
thank you
any further questions
okay I've got a couple myself oh
um I cannot wait try to save myself by
the end
um and one of them was already asked and
answered
um there's no info in here about who can
remove them if they go past the date no
there isn't and uh we didn't put
anything in there and so I get a
combination of things there I have
landowners do it which which always
concerns me for the many reasons I've
told you we didn't we didn't put a
restriction in here that only we could
do that I think it was just an oversight
but I I have concerns about landowners
doing it just because as I told you
earlier if they don't return it right
away is theft if they do damage to it
they're liable for the damage I'd prefer
that they call us and a lot of
landowners do that and we go in and
remove them so
okay uh next comment we already did talk
about the date but are you stuck with
January No my only thing I would ask you
to no my uh I I think we picked that
date because it was it was the end of
the year
um uh the only thing I would ask you to
consider is wintertime Cuts because a
lot of times this pre these Cuts happen
in the winter months they can't do them
any other time so that would that might
get in the way of that so this may be a
better question for the Timberland
Runners Association I would agree uh I
might call him back up but I'd like to
know what what times what months they do
cuts in I do think it's important to
pick a date I think you have to have an
absolute date but I but I'm not sold on
what I do agree with you that if the
name's on it and they have to do a cut
there they can obviously reach the
person sure and if the name's not on it
then obviously it's a violation anyway
right uh you have written permission
again was that intentional because that
was in the law existing so written
permission was existing correct you have
Express written permission yeah that's
because they have to have we have a
permit and then down below you just have
without written permission right which
and that law has been that way for many
many years we've never made a case if
again if a landowner because a lot of
times land owners won't write it down
and so if we go in and we find a tree
stand and a hunter tells us they have
permission but they just don't have it
in writing we've never held anyone
responsible for that so as long as they
have permission another another point I
was going to make on that is if if a
landowner is asked to give written
permission to use a tree stand they may
be hesitant because they may think that
they're taking on liability by letting
someone go up a tree I will tell you
from personal experience I've asked for
it many times and they've told me that
so and so we don't hold hunters or
Sports men and women to that if they as
long as they have permission so would
you mind if that went to permission
instead of written permission
I would not mind that okay no I would
not
we talked about name yep
the only other thing I have down here
um
is the date yes again 60 days
I know that 60 days after passage oh oh
the effective day effective date yeah 60
days after passage seems to never work
well for uh any anybody that has to make
rules around it I think OLS picked that
we didn't so OLS has been doing that by
default and it's caused a lot of
problems which is why I look for it now
sure sure so that should be next
calendar year correct I'm fine with that
yeah
oh right that's all I had any other
questions representative Smith thank you
Mr chairman and thank you Colonel I just
like to get clarity you just stated a
minute ago
um if a homeowner or landowner removes a
stand it would be considered theft but
we discussed that during the game camera
Bill and you should be could be yeah
it's not an absolute thing so if you
took I'll give you an example of when it
could be considered theft if you took a
tree stand
um and you didn't return it to the
landowner you couldn't identify the
landowner or you could identify the
landowner you just didn't get around to
do it and uh and a property owner or the
owner of the tree stand knows that you
have it and you failed to return it to
him they call us and reported as stolen
and so that just creates a whole mess
from you seizing it you it is excuse me
it isn't a guarantee you would be
charged with theft
if you make a reasonable attempt to get
it back you you wouldn't be yeah no
that's that's uh it just puts you in
that position
okay any further questions at all
thank you very much seeing none uh
you're uh all set and I saw a question
oh you wanted to ask him a question
can you do it offline or does it is it
something the committee might want to
hear
if it's something the committee might
want to hear you can join him at the
table and use the microphone
concern I guess the liability thing I
got thinking about and uh so if you have
a tree stand or somebody's put one up on
a piece of property and naturally it's
not going to be in the backyard but
there's Woods roads and trails and
because the kids play on them and
whatever so would the land only be
liable for these kids under a certain
age or above a certain age if they try
to climb that thing and get hurt
who's going to get sued well you any
just remember anybody can be sued for
anything right or wrong so I think my
point to that was if you are engaged the
largest specific to outdoor recreation
so a hunter is doing that a kid running
up the tree because he wants to get a
see what it is is not doing that so I
think the window opens a little for the
landowner maybe some responsibility
I I won't say that you wouldn't win it
because I because I I think you probably
would but it would cost you money it
could it could yeah it has a similar
incidence like when they get a
playground set in the backyard yeah and
maybe you've told the neighbors and
their kids they're not to be over there
and they come anyway so I'll add into
that that you should look up the
attractive nuisance laws
because the attractive nuisance laws are
the ones that govern the playsets that
aren't fenced in the pools that aren't
fenced in in any of these other
situations where what you've provided is
an attractive nuisance that may attract
people to come onto the property and
then get themselves harmed and it
requires that you take reasonable
precautions from somebody doing so in
the case of a pool it means putting a
fence up around it and that fence is
supposed to be a deterrent and a signal
to the person you're not welcome here
so
um the attractive nuisance laws would
probably be the same as the swing set
and in that type of situation
okay
thank you
all right I guess I'm going to close now
the hearing
um on sb15
foreign
for today
I'll tell the committee we will not be
executing these bills until at least the
25th
and I will let everybody know more about
that as we get closer to it but uh it
won't happen next week and the week
after I'm going to be in Quebec so uh
the 25th would be the first Tuesday that
we could actually take any action
use that time to read up on the laws and
think about what we've heard
that's what happened